I think we're live guys you know the
drill let us know I think it's happening
John tell us people I think we did it
yes I think we are if we're live you
must you must mention to us that we are
live and that you could hear us that's
also the most crucial part of the stream
yes um it's the part everybody looks for
no we are live it is just James can you
hear us it's live we're expecting this
to be a relatively calm stream John say
hi to people while I adjust this the
chat hello Christian unpronouncable
thank you for being here just James
Grayson ham uh
hermalin interesting you remind me of a
different name I'm used to seeing in
here but I think you are a different guy
random a the laser High man zizzy Aussie
the nerdy wave yr expert criminal got to
get some tips from you
Stevie main 7g dude lots of interesting
new name this will be this will be cool
cuz we're on a Wednesday Today back in
the day was a Wednesday
Wednesday shout out to all them Dane
Cook fans out there yeah now is a time
may
be hey man people uh people you know
they love D cook but anyway stim pulse
how you doing komaromi how you doing Ali
Victor Hugo Janine what's up Janine the
machine in the chat good to see you miss
you lots all right I think I got
everything adjusted everybody give a
hand in the chat for Gregory yeah please
why I'm here he's been here rearranging
stuff new news has broken and he made
sure that we got it all in the relevant
information for you guys so you know
what we're going to be talking about
today we must get started ladies and
gentlemen here we go enough John can you
close that please so the cats don't get
into there all right well John's closing
that um thank you guys for being here
normally we go live on like Fridays or
Saturdays but with it being Thanksgiving
weekend we thought we'd do our live uh
on Wednesday before Thanksgiving and
plus we got Doctor Who coming out on
Saturday and uh okay so a couple things
we want to get out of the way things
we're going to talk about today that I
did not think it would be the the thing
we that is going to be so predominant
but we have updates about Scream 7 um
many of you guys I'm sure have heard by
now about lead actress the star of the
the latest installments of scream
Melissa Barrera she has been fired and
now it got reported officially Jen Orga
has also left and so we're going to talk
about yeah positive news yes guys we're
all happy
WIS so yeah so we have that and then you
know like we wanted to talk there's like
a a big variety of things that you guys
help dictate the entire stream based
about what's going on in the chat if you
haven't been here before but you know
like there's other things that we've
been hearing about Superman Legacy
casting with Nicholas Holt and you you
know we also have like Marvel's box
office and there's a whole bunch of
other things as well massive thank you
to everyone who did contribute to the
last stream I was not present for that
one but I saw you guys were extremely
generous and that really helps out a lot
because playbacks on these are not the
greatest uh so the support that you guys
show it's a it's a it really does go to
help out significantly but we always
stay in tune with the chat even if you
can't contribute that's a uh we just
want to just talk about some stuff you
know it's fun to actually do a live
stream that's not just about Marvel and
DC even though I'm sure that will be a
big part of the topics for today yeah
and even if it took some some pretty
controversial and harsh news to get us
talking about something other than Mar
th% which those whoops were jokes people
I'm not happy that they have been fired
it's actually pretty messed up talk
about it okay so let's talk about the
first thing let's just get it out of the
way let's talk about the main thing here
um Melissa and also for you're here for
you being here uh please go ahead leave
a like on this video that would mean a
lot alrighty Melissa Barrera fired uh
from scre s so she plays the lead
character whose name I am totally
blanking on right now Sam carpenter
carpenter sisters yes Sam Carpenter and
what you know what John we do not we
this is our live streams are extremely
hangout if you want professionalism set
up with tech crew all that that's what
the John campia show is for okay and and
then maybe Star Wars Theory or something
what did what did spy glass say exactly
cuz this was the part oh yeah yeah we
should get what spy glass said cuz that
is um is is kind of baffling on on
what they said it John while I'm pulling
that up why don't you uh you know kill
kill the time here and tell us what you
what what comes to memory here while I'm
like typing nothing I mean yeah I I I
recall spy glass releasing a statement
of some sort basically to the effect
that you know we don't tolerate any type
of anti-Semitism or false claims of
genocide or ethnic cleansing or any
other of those you know pretty harsh
buzzword uh and so they are basically
implying that uh most of the things that
uh that Melissa Barrera was posting are
you know false or
misinformation and you know they are
taking a no tolerance stance on that um
you know I I think a lot of us in the
chat have probably all seen her post by
now but uh but yeah she's been let go
for basically you know expressing a very
Pro Palestine free Palestine stance
essentially um okay here it is I found
it I found it hey here's what it says
just in time spy glass's stance is
unequivocally clear we have zero Toler
spy glass are the producers of the
screen franchise and here's the thing
guys uh the scream franchise is my
favorite horror movie franchise so while
it's not like the biggest number
generator for us on the channel or some
like that this is one that I'm
going to be following closely because
this is my favorite Fran horror
franchise uh spy glass stance is
unequivocally clear we have zero
tolerance for anti-Semitism or the
incitement of hate in any form including
false references to genocide ethnic
cleansing Holocaust Distortion or
anything that flagrantly crosses the
line into hate speech now here's the
interesting part about it you can find
do someone put together a a giant thread
on Twitter because when this got when
this got released normally when
something like this happens you can kind
of see it coming where perhaps Melissa
Barrera was saying some online and
then you start seeing on social media
people calling for her to be fired you
know like fire this woman or whatever
and then that wasn't happening so this
kind of this was sort of unexpected and
then people were pretty much
going where's the
anti-Semitism where's the part where she
is clearly when you when the this thing
that spy glass is saying where is that
and it's just a lot of people going wait
I'll find it just give me give me a
second if you squint hard enough a post
I mean there there are a couple of posts
in there that flirt with confusing the
line but even those aren't very blatant
or or at least they are unclear and
that's kind of how they're interpretable
as you know yeah I mean for the when you
boil it down to what she's and and look
John and I are not going to be the ones
that you're going to go to for um the
the the political conversation on what's
going on in Israel we're very still
learning about all this and it's a big
thick confusing issue to balance out in
your head yeah yes and it it's it's very
it's very complex and um the whole thing
though that what all I can speak to is
is what Melissa Barrera has been talking
about and what it essentially boils down
to is her she's been saying I want the
PE I want a ceasefire and I want the
hostages return she has made it very
clear that she is not anti-s like she
supports Jewish people and Palestinian
people that it's not
about when she's saying like free
Palestine when she is talking
specifically about um being
anti-genocide or like for me you know
when you see like the atrocities that
are happening to innocent civilians
that's what she is talking about you
know the casualties of War usually being
civilians yeah and so that is where her
heart and her messaging has been and
been talking about how she feels like
the media is primarily focusing on the
Israel side and not so much of what's
going on with the Palestinians so that's
all it's really been she hasn't been
anti- Jews you well she's bent over
backwards in a lot of these posts to
differentiate like you know the IDF is
not all of the regular people living in
Israel is not the Jewish people Hamas is
not the entirety of the Palestinian
people there are a lot of just regular
humans caught up in this that are you
know bearing the brunt of you know the
violence and the atrocity and whatnot
and uh and yeah I feel like you know she
is and there are you know plenty of
Jewish people who do not support you
know these actions as well and she
acknowledges that and and yeah I don't
know she's been it seems pretty careful
not to flippantly dismiss any one group
or culture people with these post she's
also been extremely clear on her stance
for the like there's been sentiments
that she is Echo that I have said on my
social medias as well because like I
said I'm not the most well-informed the
part the I started really learning about
this recently like we got people here
who come on the channel who I'm not
going to say that some people have
brought them up in the chat you know
that I've talked extensively about it
with them my wife is actually very well
informed on these matters as well uh
what's going on in Israel and Palestine
and it's something that I've just been
learning about and the part that speaks
to me the most like there's been times
where you well I look more out of it
than I already normally do where like
John and COI have come into the room and
they're asking me why I at I'm like was
I was just up all night is it just the
normal
reason it's like heart-wrenching Terror
like I'll be up all there have been
times where I'm just up all night like
watching the the Raw videos of what's
happening to like the children I'm
trying to watch some of my words here um
of what's happening to the children out
there and that's the stuff that really
with me basically and so with her
her sentiments I've always been about
that and like and her sentiments have
also been about how hey look we might
disagree with what's going on with the
governments um but that doesn't mean
that we have to be prejudice against
Palestinian people or Jewish people and
she's Prett pretty explicit about that
yeah so all this to say I behemi
disagree with spy glass's um decision to
firing her and the and the way they
formulate it about because it's it's
already hard enough for an actress an
ethnic actress at that to to get work
and to to essentially Blacklist them in
this way is so up it's messed up
and they're also ruining the franchise
and now Jenna Ortega herself is
reportedly left the franchise as well
and now there was already the
speculation prior that she'll be leaving
oh my God we got a couple of super I
didn't even realize we so focused at the
convers thank you for the super chats
thank you guys you guys we will get to
them I promise absolutely um and then
the other part is like JGA now has left
the franchise and it you know there was
already reports that she might be
leaving due to her scheduling with
Wednesday and because she's a busy woman
she's a superstar and she got a finished
Beetle Juice too as well yeah they had
like two days left on filming those two
days yeah yeah um needless to say this
has left a really negative stain on the
scream franchise like
it's everything they do now is just GNA
there was something that felt like a
true and like if you look at the screen
franchise after West Craven's passing to
then get different filmmakers involved
you needed filmmakers who really knew
this world and really understood the
voice of it and could also bring their
own voice to it and then they had to
create new characters you can get
invested into and granted you know I
think we were kind of on the same I
think you liked Melissa barrera's
performance more than I did in Scream
five but by Scream Six I I loved what
she did and I was so on board to see
like man what are they going to do with
her character it seemed like are we
watching a secret origin of a new ghost
face this entire time you know that's
what I kind of the impression I was
getting I wanted to see it unfold and of
course Jenna Ortega being one of the
best actresses working to day to lose
these two who are the new faces of them
we've already lost Nev Campbell um I I
feel like the scream franchise is now in
just utter disarray and it has
drastically affected my emotional
association with the franchise now just
from how they're handling it even the
director came out said something along
the lines of this like I don't really
have a comment on this this sucks it was
not my decision you know uh it's really
it's really up uh what's going on
and I I do not agree with the firing I
know there's a lot of like whataboutism
already occurring on the internet of
comparing it to other people's
situations I do think it's unfair when
you see PE celebrities on the complete
opposite side of the stuff uh Melissa
Barrera has been posting but the
sentiment is pretty much the same you
know like we don't want the civilians to
be getting slaughtered yeah it's just
not as cut and dry as as you know people
being removed from things for uh you
know intimate misconduct I guess I'll
say uh or you know violence uh or or
things like that you know this zeros you
in on the idea that whoever's making the
decisions at spy glass or like with the
Susan sandon uh situation getting
dropped from her representation you know
this comes down to something I think a
bit more complex than just a universal
ideal of like racism is probably bad or
or you know being a sex pest is probably
bad yeah you know like agreeably bad
whereas this yeah I think there are a
lot of miscon strs of you know
sympathies toward the regular
Palestinian people and and turning that
into anti-Semitism and that's one of the
big problems of the cult hey 3C oh you
know 3C hey Chris in the chat thank you
hey um we were gonna get to you guys
Chris did put out a video uh about this
yesterday and uh it's a it's a really
it's it's a it's a brief one but it's I
I think he speaks he speaks efficiently
on the matter that I think is very
impactful at the same time and I think
he Echoes a lot of the feelings that
we're all essentially feeling yeah well
and and I mean this is I mean you know
private companies can do what they want
but this is one of those things where
this is an ongoing situation it's very
muddy and it's based on a lot of
complicated history and and reading her
posts and seeing how careful and and
careful both in terms of like phrasing
but also so careful in terms of
compassion she seems like she was trying
to be it it does smack of something
different than just like oh you stepped
out of line and you need to be punished
for this it does feel like somebody at
the top of spy glass just has a distinct
ideological disagreement here and so
yeah it doesn't feel fair in the same
way that like somebody being booted for
actual bad behavior feels somehow Fair
someone in the chat what someone in the
chat said
free
[Laughter]
Palpatine you never know when you're
going to get a little ch's going by so
fast that I almost missed it s okay free
free Palpatine as well you know maybe
he'll chill out maybe the Galaxy will be
better for it Jesus Christ um I don't
know there are a million trillion things
to say about this but it is it does seem
uh dissent well yeah I
mean again like people are bringing up
hey they got the the the you know like
Noah schnap I don't really know what
Noah schnaps I saw was the one post
going around kind of the opposite is him
kind of very very Pro distinctly
pro-israel and mocking you know the
other side cause right
essentially and that's kind of the point
of it's kind of weird with like her
talking about the unfairness in the
media well and then you see like what
happens to Susan Saran and Tom Cruz
having to step in and save his agent you
know like a whole back of wordss in it
of itself yeah it's kind of it's kind of
it's it's a really messed up
situation and um at the end of the day
like what it boils down to guys is like
regardless of the political sentiments
you got to look at what she was actually
saying and what the intent is and it's
not what spy glass is saying that she
said it's just it plain and simple it's
not yeah and and no matter what what
aboutism we do or what other situations
we want to compare it to let's just look
at the immediate situation right now and
it's not what she did but I would be
curious to that at least that's my take
on it that's my take on it what do what
do you guys in the chat feel about it
you know yeah it's a super subjective
interpretation yeah definitely of of her
definitely words I know it's easy to say
can we have a non-political stream but
the firing is unfortunately due to
there's a politicism we're not giving
you the history of the conflict but it
does I mean her comments on it we have
to at least kind of dive into that side
of the pool a little bit yeah do you
guys think that Melissa should have been
fired I'll ask you guys in the chat
right now and we'll move on to some
other subjects um yeah I want to check
out these super chats see what's going
on in there but yeah know there's other
topics we do want to get to this is the
main one that's been on our mind that
John and I were talking about really
late last night yeah and it's just one
of those instances where I do think you
know as much as people winge about like
ah Swift motion when somebody really
steps out of line This is a situation
where I'm like I don't know if you guys
disagree you could have had some kind of
dialogue or or come to the table or or
something yeah I don't know some certain
schools of thought will take any
sympathy toward Palestine is just
anti-Semitism basically I mean the Maj
it seems like everyone in the chat is
very much saying no I don't see anyone
saying that she should have been fired
no I don't think it's it makes any sense
yeah and there's some people who are
saying that like hey maybe they might
hire her back part of me is like would
you want to get hired back
yeah and people were also talking about
like put in Nev Campbell now it's the
only way to save it and I'm like what's
it going to say if Nev Campbell accepts
that you know yeah exactly yeah I don't
know what they're going to do and it and
it seems like we finally got to the
point with Scream Six where I cared
about the core 4 completely because I
actually think we were pretty close on
Scream five like I you know wanted her
to like her performance more in that
movie and then I loved her in Scream 6
so I'm glad she got to make her Mark but
I'm also sad we don't get to see that
spy glass should be fired fired from
your own company yeah I mean I I I read
through most of that giant Twitter
thread that they put out of like most of
her posts and I'm just trying to find I
I was try I was really examining to try
to be like is there something here that
I am totally missing uh is there it's
like a roack to like I I heard the
headline and it was before people
started responding so I was like oh God
what did she do and then I went and
looked at this very thread and the
further I read I was like okay okay
when's the either I am very distorted
myself and cannot see this or where is
the anti-Semitism happening and then
people started to freak out about it I
agree with um Janine's comment in the
chat that yeah conversation should have
been had it seems so impromptu I mean
maybe there was a conversation happening
uh but at the end of the day she was
standing by what she believes in and she
I get she wants to be on the what she
feels at the right side history and some
people feel like hey you um you're an
actress you shouldn't say this and
it's like well it's her own personal
social media you know what I mean and
she's allowed to talk about whatever she
wants it's part of the free speech of
things you know and I don't I don't feel
like she I don't think she was way out
of line no I don't think she said
something like completely insensitive or
or immoral again it's like even if you
don't agree I feel like there's there's
so much Nuance to this and also to the
way that she's posed her thoughts you
know to to the way that she's considered
all the things that she's saying and
addressed criticism in these posts and
stuff like that like yeah I don't know
Alissa said that Jenna is the one who
told her she got fired I wonder if
that's true oh goodness I mean you know
Jenna Ortega is you know well documented
in the chat here certainly shares
similar views so I can't imagine you
know she's heartbroken not to be back
yeah either way even if she really does
just have uh a Wednesday scheduling
issues or whatever which which the guy
from Wednesday just got booted for you
know alleged misconduct of a more
concrete
variety weird times all right
well all right I mean uh I'm I'm just
gonna see what's going on over here
really quick uh I I want to I want to
read what Chris said since we're on the
subject and Chris is is one of the the
main faces here
of uh 3C films is like when scream stuff
is coming out like he's he's the go-to
guy I don't think spy glass tanks I
don't think a lot of the average public
will really know about this oh but if
spy glass wants to offer us if we want
to be S want to be Sam and ter we'll
gladly take it yeah yeah I just want to
throw that out there bring the contract
you can use my AI identity
andu we're totally okay mhm we what you
call just following the C Crow here
we're cultural scavengers I'll say I
mean the last thing I keep wanting to
move on uh but you know the it's a weird
it's it's a it's an interesting thing
because I'm often seeing people going
why aren't many celebrities speaking out
about what's going on right now and then
something like this happens when you
hear about what's going what happened at
CA with Tom Cruz's agent when Su
surandon and now bissa Barrera and
you're like oh no wonder a lot of people
are really well and it's it's not like
we should expect people to it's just
usually when something really big is
happening in the world you hear a a
large influx of celebrities you know and
you're hearing a lot of people who you
who you might expect to say something
like not not even like voice an opinion
and it's not like we again we don't need
to hear them it was just kind of uh
there wasn't drawn that you didn't hear
them talk about it yeah these are
usually the people with the cultural
water cooler and I mean it it does it it
makes me just really quick it seems in
my life Narrative of how things play out
it's like we've had all this practice
with these you know water cooler issues
that are like we said very cut and dry
about the cultural confrontations of
sexism and racism all that stuff whereas
this is like really murky and like it's
dividing friends dividing families and
like people feel very very strongly and
like the amount of information to
misinformation all that other stuff is
like so dizzying that like I I it makes
me look back and I'm like we've already
had a trouble you know dealing with
issues that are at least much more black
and white than this is and now it's like
the training wheels are off and we're on
a motorcycle with an issue like this and
I think it's daunting for a lot it's you
know it's like I don't have much reason
like no one comes to me in a public
setting for like thoughts on this but
this is one of those things where I'm
like God even when I have a thought I'm
like I gotta I think about it like five
or six times then I I don't want to
speak I just want to kind of listen and
take in and see what I can learn because
I never feel like I know enough about
this yeah you know
yeah it's you know I would say that the
chat here for the most part know like
obviously there's some people here who
are upsetting some people absolutely
support the lgbtq community absolutely
sorry just in case as as you'd expect
there are people here who are
upsetting at the same time I I think for
the most part you know you guys are
doing a pretty civil job you are you are
I was a bit apprehensive about going the
last time I was on a live stream was
about the Marvels and that was rough for
me so to see this uh it is actually
pretty interesting but yeah we don't I
don't I don't not saying that I think
celebrities they must talk about it it's
just there are some celebrities where
you usually hear them talk about things
yeah and then to not hear them talk
about stuff was kind of a it was like it
did catch my eye like huh why aren't we
and then you see that oh okay well damn
this could be the thing is is like
sometimes the the popular opinion is Not
In the Heat of the Moment when you hear
that phrase I want to be on like the
right side of History you know what I
mean a lot of the
time that is not the popular opinion in
the moment when history is being made
yeah you know so I'm not saying what is
right or wrong it's just when it comes
to what Melissa Barrera was specifically
talking about if you really go into it
she has been very vocal about like hey I
got a lot of like Jewish people in my
life who are being a and I see it it's
it's something that really upsets me in
my personal life is that they're I hate
seeing people who are Jewish or
Palestinian being ostracized condemned
just for being Jewish and Palestinian
when it has nothing to it's like they're
just people it's they're not the they
not actually your nation yeah and I mean
somebody racism at that point you yeah
and somebody in the chat said like
genoci is is a simple thing and it is in
concept but there's so much political
entanglement around it and here in
America where we are allied with the
nation of Israel and we have a complex
history of colonization and and things
like that of our own to deal with I I do
feel like the it's the surrounding stuff
that over
complicates people trying to say
genocide is bad gets over Complicated by
all the other stuff that surrounds this
particular situation so while it should
be easy to kind of do what Mela barera
is trying to do and go hey all the
needless death on both sides of this
should probably stop and genocide is in
fact bad like that shouldn't be
controversial but yet here we are
because of yeah yeah these complex
entanglements and the fact that I mean
there are so much deep back and forth
trauma for both of these communities
like yeah I don't know really how you
untangle it until everybody just decides
to stop you know but maybe they should
bring back Stu they could bring back
Matthew Liller he never died he never
died you could bring back Jamie Kennedy
he never died uh you know bring back
everybody Cedric plays we're trying to
say it shouldn't be complicated but you
know it shouldn't be but here we are are
and people are getting fired for talking
about what shouldn't the aspect that
should supposedly there is a ceasefire
in the talks right now um let's see what
Happ see how that
goes anyway should be nice anyway yes
tiptoe and for
real yeah no we we are being a little
more careful because we don't want to
act like we're the experts on this on
the specific subject and sometimes it is
but we are being honest about our
feelings you know we live in America so
like confidence and and lonerism is the
is the sauce but I feel like some issues
you should be delicate about until you
are at least confident that you're like
fully informed so yeah of course be
delicate why
not hold I'm trying to get this going as
long as you're not being inauthentic in
the pursuit of you know being delicate
or whatever John I can't hold this up oh
golly let's let's fix it that's why
you're here
buddy I want to see what uh we got a few
super chats I want to just read I want
to read them really quick give them the
time of day
um all right we're gonna build some new
gonna build some new we we've just had
some live stream stuff going wrong here
all right so we are going
to call that hey sorry gang you're going
to see the the nuts and bolts for a
minute here uh let's just kill that wind
that what what is that don't worry about
it okay all right just fixing a couple
things really quick yeah
um what happened to our we we're using
OBS everything was set up yeah I want to
get rid of I
don't
okay
anyway stall I'll I'll I'll stall while
you do it John fix this all right yeah
no I agree with your comment there Sidra
about it about being against government
does not mean you're against people it's
like we're American we could be against
parts of the of of the you know often
times you hear about this left and right
arguing with each other you know and
it's there's a reason why is because the
left doesn't agree with the right the
right doesn't agree with the left it
doesn't necessarily mean you're
anti-American even though sometimes that
disagreement might lead people to think
that you're anti-American it does not
equate to that like there there are
Parts in the political spectrum of
America that again no expert in but
occasionally I'll get involved in a
conversation I'll hear something and I
don't agree with it but it doesn't mean
I'm anti-American at the end of the day
I'm I'm happy to be American yeah we're
at least we're in very fortunate
position right now free
and does Greg ever not wear a headband
not these
days
I mean yeah John you're getting the sord
don't worry buddy it's it's you figure
it out darn it uh yeah
ex oh my God no h we're so close the
dimensions I'm not against government
but I am against ghosts that's why I
support the Ghostbusters sure why not
why not we'll go with
that okay on the playback we should
remember to cut this part out yeah
definitely going it worked and now I'm
going to do it a third time
you got this John I believe in you all
right here you guys are going to see the
thingy again and we're going to take the
W again this is good this is for all you
who want to have your own live stream
this is how the sausage is made and I'm
really not sure what happened with the
stream but John will fix it you know
instead of closing everything out and
refreshing it oh did Napoleon flop is it
flopping people are saying a couple
people said in the chat that it flopped
Ridley is Ridley being a grouch
I mean yeah the guy seems to get more
contener as time goes on dude that's
that's the Greg word now I love it it is
my word it's my new favorite word this
your new fave it's good we should all
have a fave piece of brast you don't got
this I don't believe in you that's the
motivation that I need right now what
are you going for John is this all on
screen right now can everyone see this
nope all right no they cannot see any of
it and I'm going to change the uh
Dimensions
shortly yeah guys so Express VPN is uh
hiding us right
now we are so money baby how did
Napoleon FL didn't Napoleon like just
came out yes Napoleon just came out oh
my God John you did it hey you did it in
fact we can crop this a little bit
further let's just uh let's just work
with what we got right now John sure why
not well we're already here I mean now
we got that chat hidden there's there's
that's why I'm trying to crop this just
a little bit more all right
key percolating so got down John's words
right there alrighty we're gonna have to
change up the vibe of this stream as we
John did it everyone give John a round
of applause John does what he can
appreciate you Johnny all right let's
read I want to read I want to make sure
we get to Chris's chat let me just do
some minor adjustments here we're doing
this in a very relaxed Cadence today
ladies and gentlemen yeah that's how
we're gonna we wanted we're like let's
just relax today because we don't know
how heated today can get so yeah we're
trying to get this a little light yeah
all righty let me move this down yeah I
like I like the look of that uhhuh that
is aesthetically pleas there we go all
right John how are you feeling John are
you good I'm so good I'm excited to make
another one of these when we go to
streamlabs right it's GNA be great thank
you John anytime all right so Johnny and
thank you for the Super Chat the first
one kicking it off for both how many
DVDs do you have are you going to buy
Oppenheimer thoughts on Best Buy ending
physical media while Nolan defend
physical media I am a th% buying
Oppenheimer y uh my wife recently was
watching The Hunger Games movies on
streaming and I she was watching
Catching Fire specifically and I told
her it doesn't have the IMAX ratio she
didn't know what I was talking about
because she been watching an IMAX and
for a lot of people what they don't know
is that in the first part of Hunger
Games Catching Fire it is shot regularly
and then after a if you haven't seen it
a death happens and then when she enters
the Hunger Games it transitions into the
IMAX format and the entire hunger game
sequence is an IMAX format they shot it
with IMAX cameras the way how when if
you see a Nolan film like an Oppenheimer
or something how they shot that with
IMAX cameras and it translates on
Blu-ray but it does not trans but they
don't do that for streaming conversion
and I can't imagine that Mac is going to
do that oh not Max peacock right I can't
imagine peacock would do that I mean
they'd be smart to but I don't think
they will uh do that for Oppenheimer I
know Disney plus does their like IMAX
conversion thing and sometimes it looks
a little off but I think the way to get
it in in the form that no one would want
is it won't it won't happen via
streaming it'll happen via physical
media so yeah th% will be buying
Oppenheimer on physical media admittedly
I don't buy enough physical media I am I
am a negative contributor that John's
definitely more of a a contributor to
physical media more than I am I mean I
used to buy I used to buy more stuff
that I just liked I've since paired down
to like if I love this or this is a an
important film to me then I'm going to
definitely buy a physical copy
Oppenheimer would certainly be included
in that and I do think that like it's
weird I get how and why a Best Buy isn't
stocking home videos or or Blu-Rays or
whatever it is now or is going to stop
but uh I don't know it does seem as much
as there's always the march of time in
progress I do think losing physical
media is a bit of an actual issue I know
some people are like ah you know who
cares like streaming is so convenient
but like there are films that were shot
on film that have been lost to time and
and that will never be returned to us
and so yeah I mean I think what gal Del
Toro is saying is kind of true like in a
way even though it's just a little
Blu-ray copy or whatever you are like
the custodian of this and there might be
a time when nothing on the internet
carries it any longer and you've got it
so very true yeah I I very much support
the physical media appreciate the
inquiry Johnny holy Jessie that is
a extremely generous Super Chat thank
you so much I wish we still ham horn
Happy Thanksgiving to you
Jessie uh Jesse is asking I think they
redirect and shift back to Sydney's
story bring back stew maybe he has a son
could have his real face extremely
messed up from the TV falling on him and
love what you all do keep it coming
honestly I I think that's what they're
going to try to do to save face I feel
like I I think if they're going to force
that in here I think it's only a matter
of time before the filmmakers leave the
franchise themselves and they get new
directors yeah and then you also have to
count on the stars that they want to get
back not sharing these sentiments with
Melissa Barrera exactly exactly because
you know speaking of Melissa Barrera uh
the that cast really does it's something
that Chris on 3C did remind me of is you
do often would see them they they are a
cast that hangs out it's something I
always wonder about casts you know like
I I haven't seen Modern Family but I was
playing at the gym and I saw Ed O'Neal
on there and it did make me think does
he ever keep in touch with like the
other cast members of Married With
Children you know he and Sophia varara
hang out for sure that's well that's the
that's modern that's Modern Family yeah
him and Katie
hang so I was I was curious about that
and you do see that with the cast of of
scream this new crew and I don't I don't
even think you really saw that with the
original cast right because this is one
where this cast seems to keep carrying
on and now I think this seems like they
might do a rise of Skywalker situation
where they're like people are upset with
our franchise we need to Nostalgia baate
them in there let's get have Campbell
back like let's get steu in let's bring
that theory to life let's do everything
we can let's take every weird fan Theory
and make it real and it seems like the
filmmakers behind there um they they
wanted they had a very specific
direction of what they were doing with
their story with their characters they
were telling at the end of the day a
character-driven narrative that had the
Thrills and everything like that and I
can't imagine that if the Studio's like
no you got to start doing this now
that they're going to want to stay by
and then then we'll know this the the
the franchise is really going down the
yeah you know yeah I'm really
concerned about the franchise really I
really think it'll be a Nostalgia bait
franchise at this point well yeah and I
mean at least for the people paying
attention it's going to be real weird to
interact with whatsoever because you
know that they're just going to be
trying to angle you to forget about the
the real world stuff yeah you know so
and and hey you know I love movies we
all love movies but real life is more
important than movies so that depends my
escapism is often the thing that saves
me John sure that's just my take but
that hey that's just me you should
always be in a state of Escape you know
never acknowledge reality yeah never
contend with the harshness of uh you
know carrying two ideas in mind at once
uh in the chat yes I am excited for
Shelby o did a whole video about it like
when he first announced it and I am one
of his Kickstart
supporters uh but thank you Jesse that
is a that is a very very generous Super
Chat thank you very much uh really
stands out amongst the crowd even if I
got a shout out loud tonight is the only
Goofy movie yeah come on man power
line love it Dart car with a wow thank
you thank you dark car thank you Kevin
Frasier with this with this LinkedIn
profile dude n you are great sexy thanks
for everything man look at that you look
I I want I I don't know whatever you're
selling I'm buying it I love it I love
the look of it my friend bring it bring
it to me ion blos hey buddy good to see
you hey Greg missed you last stream But
I me and the fans really do appreciate
what you do for us you you're you're
bring joy to my days with each upload
thank you and really sorry that uh that
that your contributions didn't just
didn't come through last time feel real
bad about I mean you know ion's always
here and I I appreciate you always being
here and you're you're one of our and
with it being Thanksgiving I want to say
thank you to everyone who has been given
to the super chats but everyone who's
just here right now chiming in in the
chat there's a lot of names that I'm
recognizing here that are usually just
here again if you can't that's totally
okay like just seeing like even Richard
Lloyd right now uh who's let me just
make sure the chat's still going
um but yeah there's so many people here
who uh I I love seeing that it's on a
random Wednesday that we're doing this
like so impromptu oh Wednesday get it
it's Wednesday Adam and
uh where are we at okay 3C films let's
see what he say all right uh I am
pissed love this franchise and I just
don't see how they can get fans excited
again I don't even think Stu returning
would save it for me well cuz now it's
now it's like yeah it's going to be all
Shameless attempts at making you just
like over look past what they did
they're just going to try and give you
as much candy and gifts as possible and
so you're just like I don't care and I
mean you know in a post Ezra Miller
flash world there's as solid chance it
might work for a lot of people but I you
know would agree you know whatever
they're going to bring us now I am going
to be that flash work for people the
movie itself didn't work for people but
everybody still went and saw it to get
that opinion and I I mean granted
everybody went and saw it that's fair
they did
not but I feel like there are different
reasons for everybody not going to see
it than people caring that Ezra Miller
is in it I feel like a lot of people
didn't care about the movie at all so
that's probably why that happened well
you see like that's the that's the thing
about that's the thing like what what 3C
is bringing up right now Chris is
bringing up about St returning and all
that unlike a lot of other horror movie
franchises I can't say it's applicable
for all of them okay you can
theoretically do a Halloween franchise
without Lorie stro as long as you get
Michael Myers back
right technically you are correct
technically yes and I think you can
still love part three but yes I well I
mean I think four and five were still
four was really liked and then there was
not Lori stro in there yeah yeah you
have your icon you need your icon
Nightmare and Street franchise you
mainly just need Freddy Krueger the
Friday the 13th franchise you mainly
just need Jason scream is this
interesting franchise because so much
about it is not just you need the guy
someone in a ghost face mask because so
much of it rides on who's the killer
yeah who's behind the mask the and
what's made the franchise great is a lot
of the Fran a lot of those movies you
you you get invested in the characters
themselves yeah and that's why this is
so upsetting you know because we have
have gotten invested in the characters
and watching their
trajectory and it it it I think that's
one of the things that really disting
and it's also an ensemble piece and I
think that's one of the things that
distinguishes scream from many other
horror movie franchises and because you
can't just have Ghost Face being there
and stabbing people you can but then you
just got a schlocky film you yeah and
we're still currently on a timeline
where we are keeping everything in
continuity so you know yeah it's the
growth of the Sydney Prescott story Into
the extended family into the Carpenters
and how they relate back to Billy Lumis
and all so like yeah I feel like at this
point you would need to do a full ass
reboot cuz like what do you need what
are the nuts and bolts if you jump out
of the character continuity ghost ghost
face could be an actual
ghost I mean it's a funny comment I'm
excited to get silly with it sadly like
yeah part of me is like okay so you
reboot ghost face what do you need you
need the mask you need the knife and you
need just meta horror movie commentary
so like it's not impossible people
really like the show or at least it's
got a cult following um so it's like I'm
my lowest concern is like them salvaging
like they could find something to do
with it and hey they might even find a
neat part of me is like as much as I
would only want to continue this
continuity especially again after as of
Scream Six really coming to enjoy our
core 4 you know I think the only way
this works without them is if you just
completely reset everything right right
right and then it's going to be the same
problem it's going to be like but you're
still the people who with the Melissa
Barrera no you know Nash we talked about
J Orga we at the top yeah but welcome
back good to see you uh let's see here
Gary thank you so much Gary get her I
would lose respect if Nev took the role
now that's the other problem I don't
think it's a good look now if she took
the role especially right now and I mean
and and you know then that also just
says like some icky Financial stuff
about like well now that you lost your
two main stars and Jenna Ortega is going
to be much more expensive than ever
before hey you can afford
everything you know it's it's kind of
tacky tbh and like you know I doubt
Matthew Lillard needs it uh because he's
got five nights now and other things and
I mean you know the scream team does
fine on the convention circuit as well I
feel like the original screencast is
like much more camaraderie because of
conventions than like being on the
actual movie
and they can you know continue that way
for the end of time you
know it just did not
end no it's clearly supposed to continue
it just not it would be so strange and
after the really satisfying like real
life Arc of like oh this performance has
gotten night and day better from 5 to 6
now I really want to see how this
culminates with her charact like that's
the thing is they made me care about
these characters they made made me care
about her they made me it was a perfect
blending of performance and they wrote
for her and you could tell the
filmmakers were writing real life
responses to like it was so vital and
now yeah and now it's it's just a bummer
it's just like you cut the pulse
entirely and uh and unless they can find
some real weird way to sort this all out
you know I don't hey Omni I'm always
going to be thinking about what we would
have missed especially because it's like
a pretty compelling idea that maybe
she'll become a ghost phase of some kind
you know all righty so uh where we at
here Ryan Platz is saying thank you Ryan
Platz for your Super Chat my friend now
they're saying Jenna couldn't do it
because of scheduling conflicts yeah
okay yeah we talked about this earlier
in chat and
um I uh I don't think I feel like
there's way more to it than that it just
I feel like they could have made it I I
think don't think I think they would
have made it it's Jenner Ora freaking
she is so famous they would have made it
they would have undoubted FEA your cap
yeah well we got to find a way to make
this work around her schedule they
undoubtedly would have and they already
said her role was are going going to be
a little smaller already sure that they
would have found the time to make it
work fitting her in for scream is not
the same as fitting her in I know it's
it's complicated they shoot in different
areas and when they shoot for Wednesday
Wednesday is an entire season of
Television that she has to prepare for
not to mention not to forget like she
probably has other things outside of
Wednesday as well that she's booked to
do but scream
they would they yeah it's a really it's
a real I am just playing uh it's just
conjecture at this point like I'm I'm
just believing something that is not
confirmed it's just it's the timing for
me for the very following morning to be
like oh hey uh we worked this out before
the strike and stuff but uh today we're
going to announce that she's leaving
like well Omni in the chat can you read
that John there was a new update about
why Jenna left she asked her agent to
end her contract see that makes a lot
more sense like cuz again she is
documented as as sharing similar beliefs
to Melissa Barrera so I would absolutely
she seems exactly like the kind of
person who would out of solidarity just
walk cuz she doesn't need Scream now she
can do whatever she wants like she's on
top of the world and she's got a show in
Wednesday that she's got like creative
sway over too and like I don't know her
obviously we don't none of us most of us
99.9% of us don't know her personally
but what you can get gather of her
personality type on interviews is she
would be the kind of individual at least
this is just the way her personality
conveys in interviews to be like yeah I
don't want to be here anymore yeah she
doesn't seem she doesn't seem like the
type to cow toow or to playball with
this yeah uh fcking real looking real
looking real you guys thank you for the
Super Chat you guys see Noah schnap
saying Zionism is sexy wow that's a
subject yeah PE it's it is interesting
how when did he say this because
it is that is an unfortunate situation
for that individual yeah but it seems
like he said this a while ago there's
like a Tik Tok video I saw like a few
weeks ago I think so it was several
weeks ago and then now it's of course
rid to the service because there was no
punishment or Consequences for him
having his political point of view put
out there yeah people online have been
upset about it but there's been no
official to my knowledge no official
addressing of it it's just he's out
there on the internet you know in this
video well the the interesting thing
about to bring it back to what Melissa
barrera's actually arguing for at least
the the way her sentiment seem to be
most explicitly
expressed I feel like it's just given
more voice to that yeah because now her
losing her job and just damaging her
career in total like as much as there's
this online support around her still
it's an industry thing like just online
support does not equate to oh that means
she's going to get booked up now because
the online support does not equate to
that well yeah and I imagine a lot of
the money people are probably sitting
around going like well what do we do you
know because then if we hire her we're
making a direct statement about our
Ideology Now exactly you know and and it
creates a whole other conversation and
so um I think though the message she was
ultimately trying to convey that voice
for that has now just gotten
stronger so in a lot of ways it's to her
benefit for what she's really fighting
for and then otherwise is really bad
it's because it it really damages her
career I think in I think in the longer
run she'll hopefully be all right I mean
I think like she really did level up
just as an actor in that Scream Six
movie so like I feel like as you know
how whatever version of this simmering
down here in the states is I think
she'll ultimately be okay and I do
appreciate her her philosophy of like
I'd rather be remembered for the people
I include than the ones I exclude you
know I think that's a good thing um but
yeah it's like Jenna Ortega can afford
to walk cuz she's got the world at her
fingertips whereas oh is this true radio
silence still has Melissa in their next
movie oh damn oh that would make sense I
mean sure yeah that's great and I mean
you know Chris Landon is doing scream
eight so it's not like they were you
know involved with this decision I don't
think at all so so yeah and I'm happy
that they seem to have her back and they
certainly seem to in just the writing of
Scream Six and people have said I I
don't think Noah schnap like literally
said the word Zionism is sexy I think
he's seen in a video uh with a number of
people and they're all yeah the there're
stickers on the video and there are
people like showing each other content
kind of mocking uh the you know non-
Israel side of things basically I mean
the problem is a lot of time and like I
I've I've definitely in the past have
been guilty of it myself I'm not going
to act like I've never made a mistake
myself of like like uh you know you you
get you get a barrage of things you get
an immediate heat of of an emotion of
the moment of your surroundings whether
it be your algorithm or the people in
your circle you post something because
you're feeling the passion that fervor
for right there in that moment and then
you realize oh I shouldn't have
posted that I actually don't know enough
I didn't actually know the whole context
I was waiting into yeah and I've I've
definitely been guilty of making that
mistake in my life before same and
sometimes I think celebrities did like
they really make that mistake a lot you
know we're like I actually don't know I
I got I got caught up in the moment and
maybe I shouldn't have done that yeah
it's not just going to be a couple
friends or maybe a few random people who
check you it's going to be the news
cycle and the producer like a whole
bunch of people going to check you
now we're just like campia that's what I
like to hear yes our first topic
today we're yelling at the camera yeah
uh Richie brash this is a wait no I
missed one I missed
one that's a great com oh man teaser
there Joe that such a funny
comment Joe ke oh let make sure I didn't
miss this um shouts out to Jesse over
flicking real Joe Keef love you bud
loving the live stream we could just
read it right here I don't know what
we're doing because it's just bigger and
more appealing on the other screen but
yes it's much more engaging to the crowd
loving what you sit a little closer to
me we are in the we are going to get a
new table so we can we're going to get
such a long table we can lean especially
on days like this man they got to make
tables that just float that's the future
invention I
need loving the live streams recently
jents thank you Jo oh ke you Ye Ye are
an absolute Joy when life is bright and
a balm when things appear dark and murky
keep the faith love you love you too
that was a lot of accents we love you
buddy yeah and I'm glad hey if we can
bring you a little light in the dark or
just hang out and make you feel you know
attended to I'm glad for that Superman
legacy cast does look good we will get
to it there will be there will be there
will be other topics we get to will be
lighter topics we know how these streams
go we tend to spend forever on one topic
and then eventually we move on to so
variety get it's the way these streams
always go uh we will get there um yeah
originally we were leading with three
separate ones and then we were like hey
there's one that we feel the most most
uh top topical about right now yeah uh
but thank you I haven't seen that board
pick up beyond the spiderverse but again
thank you for being here like it's one
of those you know like this this channel
is our lives in in many ways it's like
all my life you know and and
um it's just so on the go and it's been
like the most successful year for real
rejects ever and then like the way the
channel has so I'm really thankful for
everyone who's stuck around with us and
has watched the channel diversify itself
with not just only covering comic book
movies and like branching out into like
other genres again and then bringing on
other hosts and everything like that and
specifically the kind of stuff that we
primarily do while keeping in the
reaction terrain with how we formulate
the videos now I appreciate it it's
become our most successful year and it's
really cool to see and then funny enough
it is one of those in the past
week within seven day within five days
five days it became like oh this is
actually the lowest amount of views
we've ever gotten on the Channel all
year oh and because I'm I'm constantly
studying the analytics and I get upset I
get obsessed I'm upset and I will get
upset when I'm just like it's low and
and um it's just what's really
interesting is like coming back here and
just even just seeing just like chat
like seeing Aisha show up in the chat
notorious sloth like see not notorious
sloth I don't believe in that comment
you um Kanye was right about which thing
just
James Kanye was right about uh not the
Taylor Swift thing that's what he's
talking about right that Taylor Swift
didn't deserve did have one of the best
still I'm still upset about that still
upset about that don't worry he's in a
tent in Saudi Arabia recording music
it's he's going to change I had a second
where I had to go wait a minute I don't
recognize that name let me see what he
said yeah he he does it with Jewish
women so he's not anti W PV thank you um
mrd so my my point and my point is that
uh but being seeing a lot of you
familiar faces here has reminded me
again of like you know what this
I've I am really grateful for just
having the support even when I was like
at the I was like exercising day I was
looking at some other numbers and I was
going you know what even though it's
been the the least performing week we've
had all
year it's still better than other years
we've had
and we're still getting like these like
residual views on other videos that are
older and I'm like that's really cool we
didn't used to get that so I'm really
grateful for everyone uh here and even
people just randomly showing up cuz like
our live streams don't get that many
views like our live streams are not like
the most like you can go to Channels
with much smaller subscriber counts and
they'll get like 5,000 people watching
all the time and so we we just we'd like
to just be a very relaxed version yeah
on these streams let when Ko's here when
he's just like
what you say I hate you can I start
beef with free goira th% oh minus one so
excited all right I'm going to show John
a video on my phone oh good and maybe I
can figure out how to put on the live
stream I made this last night okay we're
going to get Johan's reaction to this
video I made
okay I think we can put it in I'm pretty
sure I don't know if we can hear oh no I
I know how we can do I just want you to
watch it yourself I made two versions
John okay
um uh we'll call this one the original
version and then we're going to show you
then I'm going to see if there's a way I
can airdrop it and then show you guys on
the Stream but first I want to see if
it's worthy oh thanks for binging the
old
videos what do we got yeah I mean
there's a whole like algorithm thing to
it when you start like doing something
that is a low performing thing then it
affects your next uploads and because
the algorithms like the it's
it's so bizarre then you're like ah crap
now I'm stuck with this show that has
low performing views but we got to
finish it and then it affects like your
next uploads and it's this whole process
of of like studying the algorithm
of stuff but hold on a sec I will bring
back those Super Chat custom audio drops
I will I just want to show John those
really quick John John can you hear you
can't hear I can't hear it let's do this
all right listen
[Music]
listen all right now the extended
version it is
what
[Music]
yes
yes I mean there there that is part of
Watson's
personality it's a perfect blending of
like if you know this cat you could if
you go to I mean Olivia put it on her uh
on uh on her Tik Tok but yeah oh that's
beautiful I I basically took my cat and
I blended it with the Godzilla sounds
yeah anyway I think you br's comments
hilarious guys Richie is Richie
who is a stand up comic has made a
hilarious comment now General Orga
schedules open to play Silver Surfer
well this gives us a chance to talk
about the Silver Surfer thing oh yes uh
did you hear the rumors John Silver
Surfer female MCU in full force man
women can't surf what what are they
going do I need my penis you
say I need to know that this guy's got a
bulge that I can stare at instead of
other things to you know smooth out
Ken's style instead I'm not saying that
I need Silver Surfer to be a man I'm
saying it doesn't really bother me right
now like I'm not here I'm not here to
say oh yeah th% let's go woman on on
Silver I'm not going to say that just
don't give her hair I I really just I
guess I don't care enough I don't really
care if Silver Surfers woman like of all
characters I I don't let me just clarify
I don't know Silver Surfer well enough
from Comics material of course I've read
some comics where Silver Surfer is there
but I could see Silver Surfer totally
being that's the thing is like to me
it's kind of like the ancient one I
could see Silver Surfer totally being
female and it not upsetting me granted
the association is very much male
physique you know yeah you're used to
seeing yeah like literally the male
physique on full display with like just
the genitals removed what relli is
saying in the chat fairness of a serpent
doesn't really have gender rule yeah it
doesn't seem you're just the herald of
Galactus right so like it doesn't really
seem like it would mat it's it's the
irony of I'm So aware of the male
physique tied to this character because
silver body paint is the C you know
silver skin is the costume I don't
really I just don't really give a
yeah I don't care like it's fine
just maybe don't give her hair just like
you know keep it keep it that that like
super smoothed out thing you know and
and it's fine who cares Joey would be
great if Jo that would be funny I think
it would be really funny though just
hopped over there get M to be the silver
server who cares Joey radstone uh thank
you Joey we do got to get to streamlabs
I know we got a couple there um oh
Janine trust me if anyone's over the
term woke it's not you my black female
friend it's me I I just feel so bad
because like before all this nonsense
like it's a good term I like I like the
term in its in its in Plato's perfect
heaven form just now it's the tone and
now the world has taken all the joy and
all the meaning out of it and now I'm
just yeah exact it's not at all what it
means what it actually as a white man I
lament the downfall of the term let me
tell the like Aisha K let me tell the
the the black women in the in the chat
let me tell you let me tell you who
don't get told enough actually what it
means
now I'm just yeah how we that it's been
taken away it was so nice to be included
in the moment let me tell you and then
my people took it and and screwed it up
for everyone sorry on behalf of all of
us crackers Joey Joey Redstone
says do you it's not woke to be woke
anymore uh you guys do you guys think
they find a new word to get mad at
um do you guys think do you guys
thinking they will continue with Scream
seven and rewrite it or scrap it all
together if they can't have net back
thanks for being cool uh a
th% think they are going to I mean they
have to rewrite it I don't think they
can just recast it who's going is going
to play them both who's going to want
that burden oh my God is g to play the
sisters don't take on that burden yes of
what actor is going to want to do that
like you got to think longterm about
your decision you really have to think
long term about it if you take on that
roll sure do you get the money for it
absolutely or do you get a chance to be
in the screen franchise
absolutely but man the backlash you will
get and the disdain you get from public
discourse that's what you got you got to
consider both of those it's like being a
scab but like times 10 you know it's
like oh this was like a messed up human
situation that now you're you know
coming in and capitalizing on sure sure
yeah
I agree I don't know I feel like they're
going to I don't think they're going to
scrap it ever I think their best bet
after this is just to reboot because
money will dictate that like the scream
nuts and bolts can go forever you know
yeah raccoon shampoo what up buddy good
to see you again did you guys watch Gran
Turismo what were your thoughts love
that Neil Blum Camp haven't seen it we
have not seen Gran Turismo no John um
refused to go that's right
I don't support the auto industry yeah
they're polluting our Earth if it was an
electric car Grand Turismo maybe but
even that's
problematic uh no I would like to see it
some people would argue it's well
because you're still using electricity
that is generated from somewhere that
still contributes to anyway two of the
people there's no way to exist two of
the people closest in my it's the thing
is I one thing I've been trying to
encourage is having conversations with
people people you you don't share the
same point of views with or or um agree
with on like political how we progress a
society Greg I that's how some people
apparently
feel my
neighbors um they these two guys marry
couple most Macho men you'll ever meet
yes also they're always out front
benching each other yeah also they
really built the house they have with
their bare hands lizo is Silver Surfer
I'm with it always they always have but
at the same time they're two of the
closest people in my
life I identify as liberal they
Republican but we get along
fantastically and we just know how to
like give each other about our
different point of view in ways that do
that do not get heated you know you
brought the car think like I want an
electric car yeah they will fight me
tooth and Dale why that is not a good
idea sure they will of course they they
got all the evidence they always my
friends who are like Republic
read this report from hton how that's
actually really damaging the environment
I'm like yeah but I want to save my gas
money every got hydrogen car Greg then
you'll just spit out water and be in
danger of exploding and things get so he
I'm like there's ways to have the
conversations where you can disagree
where it doesn't have to get heated and
and where you can saying that reminded
me about like every time I get bring
that up like they're always like fixing
their they have like four cars and
they're they've got like an RV that is
like a really fancy one they're
fixing it up all the time and um they
got they hot rods they they yeah they
got like really nice ass cars and I'm
like I got I got a car that just gets me
places you know I don't really give a
about cars I used to and now I'm
just like as long as it still works it
just reminded me like oh yeah yeah you
know with the comment you anyway hey
guys uh Sidra
zi this is the most lacad isical um they
are gay and Republican or no that's some
of you have a hard time wrapping their
head around it but yeah they are I was
going to say how many how many as they
have a lot of like our neighborhood is
mainly like there's a mix I noticed in
our neighborhood gay Republicans it's
mainly gay Republicans really odd shoot
of just this one strip y the only
heterol the neighborhood we the odd ones
out or the heterosexual couple in the
neighborhood um so uh you know but they
they're not
like the ones who will they they they
are I like so much of our friends in
this neighborhood they're all like we we
know how to have like a conversation
it's like so great to have that
diversity there yeah what gets more
diverse than G Republicans what it's
more diverse I know that's the true Mark
of progress uh MC noite is that you
there's this notice that it's your 10th
super we're going to get to it later but
but if that's yours uh thank you and and
congratulations on this momentous
Milestone John we're not going to film
the last couple episodes of of scam
today we're just gonna be on the stream
all day I would love to be on an all day
live stream it does Sidra Z oh oh I
heard about this I heard I heard about
this I heard about this a long time ago
I saw this come up and was like oh this
was one of those things that Greg had
some inside knowledge on prior to any
reports ever coming out that I just had
to keep my mouth shut about and
now now it's out for the public I was
surprised they did like a whole video
together um did you hear that machio and
Jackie Chan do a Karate Kid move
together and looking for The Next Karate
Kid I did not know they were going to do
that path this sounds like a reality
show yeah that's that's nutty um to get
the because I heard about the I mean
yeah we all heard a while ago that there
were the rumors but I heard before the
rumors came out that was like one of the
things was like o I know something but I
can't see I can't say anything oh man
can't even speculate why can't I be one
of those leak
channels but it
would it was interesting to have to
really have a piece of knowledge on my
hands not say anything about it you did
good you did good I couldn't even like
hint at it this will prove you
trustworthy in the future um and then
and I didn't it wasn't 100% confirmed
that they were going to do it but yeah
they now they're now they've made it
clear but the fact that they are doing
The Next Karate Kid and they're going to
be casting I guess that's a interesting
way to get hype around it I'm still not
really that interested in the film I'm
not going to lie Jennifer TGA Next
Karate Kid let it make it happen um I'm
not I'm not that interested in this next
Karate Kid movie regardless of this I I
think the interest that people have is
you know seeing Ralph maio and Jackie
Chan together I don't even feel like
they're probably going to be the main
stars of the film no he's gonna train uh
Ralph machio Jackie Chan I I think what
they're doing is they're setting up yeah
he's got I think they're setting up
people for um Kung fuid a terrible
expectation here that they they think
it's going to be Jackie Chan and Ralph
machio starring side by side together I
don't I don't know what the film's going
to be I don't expect it to be that
though where it's going to be them side
by side for most of the film I think
they're going to be like glorified
extended cameos I don't think they'll be
the actual stars of it but they're
throwing their handing to show support
because there was already a backlash
around this film prior to this happening
so I think this helps change the Optics
around it I think it's a great marketing
strategy yes um and then the looking for
the next Kate kid I uh man I I don't
know why they would open themselves up
to that that's that that audition
process is going to be
a a nightmare in the making yes Willow
Smith can play The Next Karate Kid oh my
God yeah I don't know I
mean are you guys excited for The Next
Karate Kid movie it is an interesting I
I am not I'm not I I haven't actually
seen the jackiechan one but but it it
it's weird it's like it's you haven't
seen the Jackie I like that's that's the
weird part for me I really like the
Jackie champ when no no one likes that
Jackie Chan and I like that one I think
it's one of Jackie Chan's best American
performances sure um uh an American
performance uh no a performance in an
American role sure God you know what I'm
trying to say American Film God damn it
but yeah I I don't uh yeah no one's even
in the chat no one's really excited for
it uh but uh I HRA Kai has more magic
than this Prospect does because because
it's the diminishing returns of we we
still have Ralph machio people like
jackiechan but it's just like right now
the prospect is just the two of them
which which is like how did they yeah
it's like how did they coales what would
their you know what would their
relationship be what would be the
driving thrust of their thing together
and like wasn't even karate in the
Jackie Chan it's Kung Fu and and that's
a tribute to you know I think they they
considered calling the original one like
the kung fu kid or whatever or they
tried to rename that one the kung fu kid
or something but yeah I don't know like
it seems like they're missing beats or
elements or something foreigners oh yeah
oh yeah The Foreigner is probably his
best best um yeah about that movie
that's a good one that is a good one um
but I I I well you see we we just know
it essentially be a remake and not
really and the Cobra Kai people aren't
involved in it and what Cobra Kai has
shown us is how you can truly take the
evolution of The Karate Kid world and
make it something that the he ly honors
the original Source material whilst
taking it in a Direction that's
unexpected Innovative but still keeping
what you love about it without getting
into terrain where you're like this
show you know and and I and and and you
just know that the movie is probably
going to be some like remake
that you don't really want to sit
through well and and the prospect of
them I I want to what this means looking
for the new Karate Kid because I don't
know I don't know I
I'm sure they can come up with something
that works but like for these two
characters I don't really know why they
would be like we just got to get out
here and find a new kid I feel like it
would need for like Danny laruso as we
have seen it would have to come from
some kind of really personal motivation
of like oh my family or something like
that I feel like Cobra Kai is just so
fleshed out that I'm not sure what this
would serve a purpose of I know this is
the most cliche answer you can give for
something like this I when I first heard
about the prospect of them doing this I
was like if you're going to do this I
think the best way to do it is take a
Phil Lord Chris Miller approach where
you just do something that's very meta
and self aware because you got to do
something that distinguishes it from
just being some remake some generic ass
remake yeah and it's the answer is not
just combining someone who apparently
across the country had the exact same
story just for Kung Fu yeah totally
because then what are you going to do
another one where it's um some other
what's going on John somebody
just sent their first so I just wanted
to acknowledge them really quick go
Nation first uh live stream Super Chat
thank you so much it's throwing these
Milestones interrupt me we could be like
the uh brothers who may talk to
me all right oh yeah oh yeah we'll be
Denny Michael philipo stop
bad Heather gear Heather
gear super sexy reject Heather gear
thank appreciate the people saying made
a great point the one one of the few
great points I make you won hey I've had
I've had a couple years to think
yeah you didn't have a take on this it'
be very disappointed um uh Heather gear
thank you for you awesome guys this
holiday season thank you you
awesome for you for you Heather for
being in our life our patreon and
constantly in our comments love you so
much John yes John hey I see the
trajectory of the stream it's a topic
scream topic scream topic scream topic
scream yeah that makes sense we got to
break it up K is busy ranting at
somebody on
Twitter Co is busy going to spy glass
entertainment right now and laying down
some harsh words uh Brian Vicor take it
away John maybe just hear me out and
thank you for your contribution uh maybe
bring back stew in a Freddy Krueger type
disfigurement in homage to Craven's New
Nightmare but use Ghost Face St as the
children's scary story five nights at
ghost face
I think we should do this uh I you know
any idea is going to have the same
response for me it's like they could do
that but I don't it's just I on this
timeline it's going to be real
conflicting and I don't think it's going
to work I don't think it make any sense
for him to come back at this point no
and it wouldn't pack the fun punch
because we just know it's like dumping
sugar on a wound I think you get in a
Saw movie territory at that point which
is where it's just like oh my God like
Ste would have to have been like a
master mind a ma a a mastermind that's
one direction or someone who has been
like kept trapped and tortured by some
other by ghost fa living in a hole
Donnie
Walberg insa yeah we're D Walberg and
saw where he just like this guy's
still just trapped he's just two movies
later he's on an ice briak he's got a
big beard poor guy yeah keeping this guy
hostage yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah um oh
we could do Rush Hour together I like
that idea
Jack watch Rush Hour now and I saw this
great video that was talking about the
death of comedy movies um that is an
interesting topic that we don't have
time to get into but rush hour is like
PG-13 but you watch it now and you're
like this would get People
cancelled now it it's a very offensive
and stereotype movie lot of stereotypes
a lot a lot of creeping especially on on
you know women and stuff it's definitely
it's yeah going back for certain movies
really is like an interesting exercise
because yeah Rush Hour you're like oh
this is definitely a time I watch I
rewatched The Italian Job a few months
ago the mark wallberg one and that one
is like this is a really fun Heist movie
but like oh my God all the character
interactions have not aged flatteringly
at all just all creepy and they're all
talking down to Charlie
there Josh ran thank you for the Super
Chat my friend he crazy pmat decided to
end the franchise at six but hey why not
go out with a bang I know bold move
subverting
expectations why don't we have a hit
with a cliffhanger yes and just never
answer it that be a legend for all
time people still wonder what happened
to Ghost
Face just do it virally you know just do
it as like a viral creepy pasta from
that one dead shot never miss this is a
very stupid decision from spy glass they
need to pull a Diddly and hire a Disney
and and hire them back even if it's to
finish the trilogy they would have to do
it with like an immense helping of like
Crow or something some kind of weird
atonement of like hey we were a bit
Hasty
sorry there's a way where you can do I
mean Disney brought back James gun and
they still made an amazing ass Guardians
film you know
and first Super Chat first somebody else
oh thank you so much at the end of the
day it's about trying to look John I've
been holding in the bathroom go to the
bathroom since I whole bathroom all the
fixtures are like go the water's going
to explod the the toilet's going to
geyser into the ceiling
no yeah yeah yeah go other still time I
can't take a under these conditions
you must okay we I can hang out with the
chat for a few minutes and I mean I
figured what we can do I mean this is
not the the like this this needs a
refresher but at the same time um I know
that
uh the streamlabs thing needs to be made
I can build the streamlabs in awkward
silence while you're I I think John will
know how to um talk with the chat whilst
building a streamlabs thing so that way
we can read the streamlab because
and yeah I think you got this John okay
thanks man I appreciate this vote of
confidence I don't know what to expect
right now you're going to do great in
there though everybody I want you
everyone leave your words of
encouragement for don't touch my ice p
I won't don't worry it's been on your
it's been on you for this entire time
hey guys all right now that Greg is gone
talk as much as you want as yes
Greg's your wre Rook mon narrow urethra
uh that's uh yeah that's that's what I
think of when I see that just to pull
who shot Jr or a saint elswhere the
events after Scream one were all a dream
ooh that would me that would really piss
some people off that would be
interesting yes Greg can do it we
believe in Greg yes droing the Browns at
the Super Bowl haven't heard that in a
minute I should get to building this um
and yes screw calling Twitter does
anybody call Twitter X if you refer to
Twitter as X comment below and tell me
why you do so uh no Greg is you can
never smell Greg you don't understand
it's some kind of alchemical uh thing he
does where just like you can't perceive
him unless he wants to you ever seen
Hunter Hunter it's like that he can just
like you know control his nen Anthony
Alba uh is fine you know uh Transformers
rise of the Beast was a very fun movie
liked it more than I was expecting to
and yes Greg is secretly going to Taco
Bell he's going to do do it I like these
comments very much and yes he is
fighting a war it is like a Transformers
movie in that uh regard oh hey there you
go there's another big old graphic for
for you guys as I build out this live
stream into something even more
advanced um yes X does sound a bit adult
no no doubt um you know which I'm sure
is what eagon intended certainly I mean
you know if there's a guy who uh
appreciates you know some some ludes
it's uh it's
Elon I don't know how people feel about
Elon but you know we all uh we all yeah
anyway Greg's coming back um he didn't
drop the bomb I don't think sadly do you
realize it's it's been like a giant week
of a lot of Greg and John hasn't been
like that all year I know so many other
people have and yet it's our lowest
viewed
week people don't like us anymore people
don't like us together anymore I don't
know what's happening here okay we're
going to do a couple little cop CPP a
TOPS oh no I hate when things move when
I don't John who remains JN is a little
taller than what are you five 10 and a
51 I am yeah I'm like just shy of six
feet yeah we got two stream Labs stream
labs are great because they take less
they yeah YouTube is less uh greed guys
watch omn
man watch him man he's great watch uh
omn media as well yeah omn media great
you should have called yourself omn man
omn man media it would have opened the
hey why didn't you plan ahead uh omn
media why don't you just see what the
dimensions are for the former one we're
just fixing the crop here see what the
dimensions are for the former one and we
could just uh I could remember it okay
so that's what this is so 1300 53 oh my
God 1300 530 50 and 500 you got it chn
I'll let you remember while I'm talking
all right I was like maybe I won't
remember
that the link the link in the streamlabs
is at the the top there The Foreigner is
a great film keep talking I'm talking
with the chat right now Kelsey gramar
just said he thinks he'll be playing
Beast again I hope so you think
can you imagine you you never know guys
you never know I'm going to have to
change the thumbnail and the title
because we barely we haven't even got
into the Superman it's okay
we'll get there
eventually hey we're here with this the
new uh display we got two right now we
got do let's do it let's do it let's do
it let's do it let's do it uh Hey the
gamer MJ thank you for chiming in they
should just sell the rights to someone
else let it be done I mean that's the
only copesthetic way I think right now
uh the rumored plot came out and
involves the core four Sydney Mark and
the kids takes place in La would loop
back to the morine Prescott somehow but
now the end of six is looking
poetic true that dude bring it back oh
my God if we could just bring it back in
seven to part three you know I love that
these maligned part 3es always get their
you know love eventually down the line
you know uh we could have had all the we
could have had perker posie back in some
weird know Patrick Dempsey back they
should always bring Patrick Dempsey
around he's sexiest man alive he's
McDreamy
how how someone pet pitched him for
Silver Surfer I
don't look I Patrick Jey he's a talent
he's a beautiful looking man I think
he's very Charming but there is a ma
there is a massive butt coming and then
sure enough his well toned butt when
when Patrick
Dempsey one sexiest man when I saw that
go out my immediate thought was please
for the love of God let Twitter be
thinking what I'm thinking right now
which is what Pedro Pascal should have
won oh sure hey first time Super Chat
thank you so much I so I I go on social
media and it was like yep yep yep that's
it I was like why not P Pedro is like
Pedro is the the moment it is who which
other man Harry Styles but I feel like
we're already past that moment no no he
had Last of Us Mandalorian his SNL
episode was like a legacy episode sure
every sketchy he was perfect in that St
and then and then the like the interview
circuit rounds he would was the talk of
the year yeah it was phenomenon it was
equivalent to when Bradley Cooper won
over Ryan Gosling you're like what this
it's such an obvious sometimes it's so
obvious staring you right in the face
like how did he how did he not I don't
even I don't even know what the sexiest
man alive thing means like a lot but
it's a big it's a big boost to your that
was that was the biggest to me
out of anything that's happened Mist
Barrera being fired as is one thing but
Pedro not but Pedro Pascal not being
sexy as man alive when we all know true
if we all know like what like what other
answer really who like maybe what did he
do I love this Theory maybe it was
offered him and he didn't want ITA he
like no that's a great great Point K
Kuan is the only other also sexiest man
honestly yeah wholesome sexy were
I'd rather I put Brendan Frasier
there for them
I don't understand I was like what did
what did patri Dempsey even is there
something he did that I completely Miss
he is z Pedro is is a total zatty other
than um um uh
disenchanted yeah what's he been doing I
could I could not tell you what he's
done hasn't he been sexiest man before I
I would have thought I don't know MF
Doom anyway uh but thank you gamer MJ
for uh leading me into that funny as new
sexy but like is Patrick Dempsey funny
um Mr Juan juar thank you for the stream
La donation here uh what are your most
anticipated non-comic movies of
2024 damn I was going to use that
opportunity to talk about Superman
Legacy uh George Miller furiosa and dune
2 much love happy
Thanksgiving uh do we have in24 damn you
really uh took the icing there of I was
going to say those would be
yeah it's really hard to to think well
scream seven definitely looking for
scream sure movies coming out in
2024 what do we got what do we got we
won't spend too much time here oh we got
a new Kung Fu Panda kungu panda 4
undoubtedly I'm looking forward to I
don't love joker as a movie but I'm very
movie a comic movie John damn it uh
Beetle Juice 2 I'm looking forward to
curious about beet very I from the the
conversation that Tim Burton has let us
in on with that film it has sounded like
he has been aware of what he has become
and he's going back to more of his roots
okay with that okay he's talked pretty
extensively about how Disney warped him
sure oh oh so he's he's Reckoning with
CGI Timber no th% he he he he has uh
talked pretty extensively about it I
didn't know that that's interesting if
um Adam Sandler and the safy brothers
are able to make that movie oh Fall Guy
that movie looks great there I know I
knew I was forgetting something and Fall
Guy 100% excellent yeah Fall Guy looks
excellent I'm very excited uh I am I'm
very curious to see what alien Romulus
turns out to be just because I like
fetty Alvarez a good amount uh you know
Wicked I'm excited to see if they do a
good job he's the right pick for
that uh I I can see how he would and
would be and that makes me Cur like Neil
Blom Camp I'm like that's the guy and
I'm sad we don't live on that timeline
same time I think fetty Alvarez can at
least heighten like the icky like horror
and the fact that the aliens are just so
harsh of a creature you know I think he
would give us a really aggressive this
like I think the sequences of alien Gore
would hit uh uh but alien needs to it's
the surrounding element
outside of the
violence I'm not exactly sure but but he
likes to have also female leads and
alien is one of those franchises where I
mean I think Horror in general is that
one genre yeah where people are like we
we love female leads but in any other
genre people are like this a
right n yeah yeah I can I can
see how it would go arai and I'm and I'm
curious I don't know if he wrote it or
not cuz like you know the the dialogue
log in some of his movies could be
better um but you know I don't at least
in terms of attitude I'm looking forward
to it and uh with that new James one
movie do we have any more uh stream all
right let's let's uh let's go back to
the soups for right
now oh the Transformers one with hemor
and Johanson the animated one that does
sound like a cool cool experience Gia I
know someone who worked on it oh that
can't say can't say a testing past can't
say but I not someone who worked on it
and they're like oh it's going to be a
good one o uh we should refresh this we
should oh goodness gracious me let's do
a big uh no okay before we go back to
the supers let's just talk about super
let's get out the way I don't
think there's anything in the chat about
Skyler
gando whoa whoa John John we got to fix
this whoa sorry no it's just going to
look like crap on screen for a little
bit let's just leave it like that all
all right let's just do it um all right
Superman Legacy Nicholas Hol Nicholas
Hol
what a lovely day I'm not going to lie
man it's not him who I'm most excited
about it's Skyler gando as Jimmy ol it
really is I I'm excited it really is
because because goddamn that guy was
excellent in Santa Clarita diet have you
seen that show oh I've got to finish it
but I have seen some of it yeah that was
the I think out of every Netflix show
that has been cancelled that is the one
that still to this day makes me go damn
it guys yeah trueberry more especially
needs a re and and just any Timothy
olant as a gift and I didn't really know
Timothy olant honestly uh like
apparently he's been like this this
beautiful Gem of a human being for
centuries and and I and I wasn't aware
of this and and uh yeah like I I I think
him as Jimmy olon is perfect he's got
that like
endearing sheepish quality that that
he's got just like that the right
quirkiness about it like just do exactly
what you did in Santa clar sure I don't
want to see you do any range just be
exactly what I know you to be and I'm
cool with that yeah well and I'm excited
to I haven't seen the righteous
gemstones but I know he's on that which
which is giving me all the more kind of
motivation to check it out and he is
actually on one of my favorite shows
which you can check out over at the
patreon he's he's on psych he's like
he's the young version of Shawn they
they re cast young sea at some point and
it becomes Skyler gando and uh and I
always really enjoyed seeing him in that
form and so he I associate him with that
boyishness from that so I'm like P you
and and now um um the uh the okay let's
talk about Nicholas Holt though Nicholas
Holt
is what has not been said about him
already that I'm like what can we really
Pro I think the the the versatility of
even if you haven't seen some of the mov
movies like like I haven't seen like a
lot of his movies but if you just go to
if you just go to Rotten Tomatoes and
you see the feedback he gets from the
versatility of roles that he has done
even for the ones we haven't seen you're
just like yeah he can easily I feel like
it's a like it's an he can easily do Lex
Luther and it is one it's there's
something that feels very classical
about the casting that they're doing
with Superman you get kind of an unknown
like
David I always want to say sweaty
bottles
Corin sweat Corin sweat Corin sweat dve
yeah like he's not bald enough D he is
like some people know his work but he's
not exactly famous yes whereas Nicholas
Holt is a is a pretty famous guy who
really hasn't had the proper break for
that huge role and yeah most of us know
him as like he played Beast he played he
was in Mad Max Fury Road Warm Bodies
Warm Bodies some warm bodies loved his
work in uh the menu M and those are
already there that level of range like
there's an undeniable range just in
those few roles alone and in a lot of
ways you kind of see how that could in
it I mean he's played like tolken you
know he's played scientists before tank
McCoy is a scientist you could already
see Alex Luther from an amalgamation of
all those few the few roles that we all
that he's pretty much known for yeah you
know yeah and his growth as an actor
haven't seen Renfield yet I heard he's
great in that I'm excited to see
Renfield yeah I mean his his growth as
an actor over time I feel like he's got
a good combination of like he still
feels like a young fresh-faced guy but
he has been around for long enough and
we've seen his chops grow enough that he
has like something of like a
veteran esque status now you know he's
well ingrained now and I think that
suits Alex Luthor kind of nicely and
having heard that you know he was maybe
even in wasn't he one of the names
thrown out for Clark you you know mhm
the audition for it if I'm not mistaken
someone just brought it up in the chat
yeah and so I think that's fun it's like
okay he came in for one thing but we see
him for something else and uh and yeah
he's like I associate him more
with more sympathetic more protagonist
than you know not but I think he can
very easily and very like I'm excited to
see him slip into this particular
villainous role and and expand on those
chops that much more because you know in
the menu he's not a very likable
character already get that sense and
yeah I'm just I'm excited to see him
really take Center Stage cuz you know
any superhero movie is just is is they
say only as good as it's villain yeah I
mean he can play like the Elegance he
can play the entitlement he can play The
Mad genius you know um I think he can
command the screen I think there's
there's so much he could the way he
would carry himself and he commun he's
one of those actors who can communicate
a lot with the eyes and there's more of
a depth Lex than just he's bad guy you
know yeah and and James Gunn has also
been kind of outspoken about not being
the biggest fan he hasn't said those
exact words but you could kind of get
the inclination in that interview did
with Michael rosenbom who is still in a
lot of people's eyes the Pinnacle for
Lex Luther um and I think that it's not
going to be like Jee Hackman at all you
know nor is it gonna be Jesse Eisenberg
no so yeah no people will right be right
in between yeah yes that's what we need
yeah yeah you know no no I mean it's a
common HD for some reason you can see on
screen Lex needs to be an ass but he
also needs to be likable to an extent
yeah cu the word th% and I feel like in
the hands of James gun we can get the
Lex who eventually gets the mech suit
yeah Mech Lex yeah well I'm excited to
see what he brings out of the
relationship the back and forth between
Superman and and him because like one of
the most play the duplicitousness yes he
can't well that's one of my favorite
things about the the DC animated Journey
that Co and I took was it showed me so
many fun sides and approaches and ways
in which Lex figures in that that make
him more interesting than just like ah
he's an arch villain like he can wind up
on a lot of different sides of the chess
board and I think that in of itself is a
really fun Prospect th% yeah th% I think
it is not the the obvious pick that you
would see but it is a great pick yeah
and I and I trust in I think regardless
of James gun whatever you feel about
what's happening with DC it is it it is
a craziness that's happening right now I
do think that there's one thing we know
about James gun is that he knows how to
cast for the work that he writes he
really knows how to do that very well
Paul Kento want James
rear that's the name you it's your go-to
name now yep James Remar always they
should get Clancy Brown Clancy Brown
would be lovely oh my God and that'd be
kind of um meta casting since he's
played Lex before yes oh I love it oh my
god do it please and he's always playing
a villain it' be nice to yes
that would be a wholesome character nice
to see him play like can't all be Mr
Crabs you can also see kind of that
Mentor I mean he's pretty old but but
hawkin's supposed to die yeah you know
in aado accident and have a heart
attack hey I mean there's some versions
of the story where he doesn't die you
know um anyway let's go back to the sup
some people have been saying we have to
read the supers we got to get supers
it's rare the the main chat is saying
you got to read the
yeah oh God what's going read the sup I
saw one confrontation at least uh yeah
okay so we got this one let's move on to
get Josh R okay wait no did we read it I
don't know if we did yeah yeah we did
yeah go out with the bang okay dead shot
decision we did not read that all right
Dakota Jones one virus effects what's up
my dude good to hear from you once again
thank you for being here just want to
say happy holidays to my brosis
what are the thoughts on javar BM as
Galactus I was close ony
brown go Clancy BR and he's got the
voice got the voice like Clancy Brown
for every he's the new uh the new you
know Brian Cranston was like the name
everybody did for everything before now
I want Clancy B for all things Clancy
Brown let me tell you what Clancy like
Javier tell you about Clancy Brown
Javier bardam I always suspect is a bad
guy even in roles where he's not
directly playing a bad guy I constantly
suspect he's a bad guy no country really
kind of defined that note for him it's
kind of like like one of my favorite
castings I've ever seen done in the
history of casting is
watching Tarantino cast Kristoff Waltz
as one of the greatest villains ever
Hans L and in glorious bastards he wins
an Oscar and then what does he
immediately do he puts him in his next
film as a protagonist yeah you know and
and uh and jeno Unchained wins an Oscar
for that you
know and and I was like oh that's so
good but then for some reason you mainly
just see um uh I just said his
name W Christ his name you always see
Kristoff wals playing a bad guy and it's
like like okay I'm sick of it you kind
of just expect him to do that you just
kind of expect him to do the thing that
Tarantino had him do but slightly lesser
right yeah that that is the vibe right
yeah Clancy Brown he can play good he's
usually playing bad but he can play good
buub banai yeah there was a uh Revival
season of uh of Dexter where they said
he was playing the antagonist now you're
not act they they revealed that prior to
the point in the show where they reveal
he is the antagonist
uh but they already announced that he is
so I'm don't feel like I'm spoiling
anything if you're if you're like late
to catching up on
this but it got to the point where I'm
watching the show and I'm going oh maybe
he's not a bad guy cuz he was so good at
selling me on that he's that he is a
good person
sure that I I was like oh maybe the
casting reports were wrong yeah and then
eventually the show was like like a
couple episodes and oh okay is uh but my
my point to that is Clancy Brown is is
one of those actors who can play that so
well I'm not saying Galactic needs to
have that yeah uh but I don't know
there's just something that feels like
jav bardam as Doom is another obvious
one that I'm like that's too obvious to
me like there's something that's like
just the right fit to me about Nicholas
Holt as Luther yeah it's the right
amount of like you can see it but it's
not quite likely yeah yeah yeah I would
agree um but I mean sure H but the
here's the thing though h r dam
is is a fantastic actor so yes like is
he a great pick I'm sure by the time if
he does the role and I'm sure if we when
he comes out and he say I'm sure we're
gonna be like he's great you know like I
I highly doubt we're going to be like I
this cast I I I highly suspect that if
he does take the role we're gonna he's
going to do an excellent job yeah it's
just the immediate announcement of it is
like a little bit more of a like that's
why I think Pedro is an exciting casting
choice to me yeah because it's not quite
what you would expect or imagine and it
requires a thread that we don't see as
much from the roles that he's been
largely associated with so yeah it's
like a little chance to grow and a
little bit unlikely but you can also
kind of see where this would work too
and yeah Deadshot to your point uh yeah
jav uh John Carlo is an exact um thing
exact thing I mean yeah it's happened
with so many many people it's like John
Carlo or oh that's right he was a little
mermaid I forgot about that that's right
was he King Triton yeah okay true I mean
I like hobby Aram more for galatis than
Doom but that's just a personal kind of
flippant thing I just I don't know I
yeah it makes more sense for him to be
this big giant thing to me and I feel
like we could get a little different
thread out of him for that than than
something else but than Doom for example
anyway uh Shakita
Washington I hope I'm saying your name
properly I have followed y'all for about
three years now I love what you do I'm
fangirling right now great job getting
healthier uh down through the years
Gregory well done and uh for your
information thank you
Shak
Washington oh also congrats on your
first uh super chit Rando we will get to
you but yes FYI I want John to be my BFF
well dude let's make this happen what
the hell because what a rude thing to
say she's nervous flying for three years
nervous to a be my best friend and the
reason she wants to be my BF is that is
so that I can introduce you to her I got
to say that is a that is the rudest
Super Chat we have ever
gotten you know what I
agree you know this is this is really
driving a wedge between us this all the
the lates the the lady followers of the
channel I would love to be your BFF I'm
excited to chat uh I I do think Ron
Pearlman is also a good pick absolutely
thank you shita shita thank you so much
for following us for so long my dear
Akash
harad hey fellas what are your thoughts
on some big budget flops this year oh
that gives us a chance to talk about
what was originally in the title do you
think consumers are exhausted with big
budget blockbusters
um personally love Mission imp possible
to Reckoning but sad to see it
underperform um you know what's funny
about um Mission imp possible dead
reckoning is now I'm seeing more videos
come out that Echo the that I said
when I first came out yeah sometimes it
takes the time now people are saying and
and I this come from someone who's a
massive fan of that franchise and every
one of those films multiple times even
even dead reckoning I was like I got to
watch it again just to see if I still
feel the same M um I don't think it's a
I I feel like that Reckoning is a step
down in the franchise as as a film I do
I really do think that I I think it's a
good big budget film but I do I still
think it's a step down and I I actually
think here's my really unpopular opinion
oh it was already unpopular at the time
now it's getting more accepted I noticed
I think even if it was not it it would
not have tanked as bad obviously if it
was not released a week before the
barbon h or experience yes I still think
it would have
underperformed I don't think the movie
itself had much of an effect that would
have warranted the amount of money that
it needed to make I I I just don't think
that I I don't believe it I really don't
and this trust me on this trust me
there's no way of knowing there's really
no way but I don't think I just like the
the film is too long the action scenes
are not as memorable or as impactful as
the the prior installments they're
they're just not they're they're good
they're great they are great they still
feel lesser than the other ones I got to
say they're less ion truly iconic
moments I guess like the dead reckoning
mostly gets tagged as the AI one rather
than like the Burge Khalifa one or the
plane one or the halo jump one you know
it's yeah it's it's the one where you
the bike stunt that you essentially saw
in the trailer yeah it's not that
different than what's in the trailer
yeah yeah and and um and I do think that
out of all of them that was the film
where because of its length where
the the the amount of exposition that's
in there and the the writing where it
does feel a little bit more perfunctory
to kind of hard you to get to the action
scenes is the most felt in that film and
uh so I do think that regardless it
would not have had the the repeat exper
like to me I I think Fallout is a near
Perfect action film MH and and at the
end of the day I think most would still
say that it's still a step down from
Fallout even if you really liked it I
still think it's still a step down
because to the point of the chat right
now Fallout and Rogue Nation because it
had three which a lot of people like
that's still my favorite one but I know
I understand that's most most people
that's not their favorite yeah and then
Ghost Protocol like fu set the
bar like whoa Tom Cruz endangering his
life for us love you again what did he
say about scientology I don't
remember then uh Rogue nation was like
whoa holy what's this guy doing
there's no way you can top this oh my
God he did Fallout you know totally and
then Fallout was like this Perfect Blend
I think of Ghost Protocol and Rogue
Nation CU Rogue Nation kind of Stripped
Away some of that Whimsy yeah and but
Nation but the anth the
yeah you yeah and and I mean Fallout has
what feels like such World rening
culminative Stakes that part of me
wonders I don't know like there there's
something about that that feels very
kind of like a punctuation and it almost
feels like the end of something and so
now it does feel maybe a little bit like
we are kind of in a new territory where
they got to figure out like what the new
Juju is because like there's Ai and
that's topical but that's not exactly
like the new
enchanting flavor of these things and I
think that yeah maybe there is a quality
of like maybe it is just like the
convolution I don't know like all these
movies are very convoluted Mission
Impossible movies certainly they thrive
on that but but yeah there's something
about dead reckoning as much as I
enjoyed it um that yeah doesn't doesn't
quite feel for as many like really well
orchestrated elements and and feathers
in its cap as the movie has there is
something that maybe feels like it's not
quite fresh or or or at least it's not
making me forget about everything that
came before guffin is so not
interesting I yeah like I I like the
idea and I like some of the things they
do with it the key the
key yeah I'm I'm I'm torn on that key
opens because part of me is like sure
but even the first one is just like we
just got to get this list we got to get
this list this freaking knock list the
freaking knock L like you know there
you're talking about the first one yeah
I'm just I'm pulling an example of like
these mean like these McGuffin that you
know mean less than just what's
happening on the franchise got better I
know I know I know but and but they all
have or or the chimira virus or uh I
mean you have part three with like these
personal Stakes so it doesn't really
matter as much like what the McGuffin is
and I think maybe there's that it's like
you have all these movies that have
other more sort of I don't know
galvanizing physical presences and it's
like you have the addition of Haley
Atwell which helps
but you have the fridging of that one
character I won't spoil if you haven't
seen it that makes you mad and then eai
Morales good performance but not like
the he's not written in a way to be like
the captivating new actorly presence
like you had with I think it's a little
bit miscast maybe and a little bit
underwritten too like I think like Henry
caval like that character didn't amount
to what we expected certainly and I
think some people wanted more out of
that but he still left his mark on that
movie or a Philip Seer Hoffman leaves
the mark on you know whatever movie or
even with four and five you have the
building out and solidifying of The
Ensemble that still feels new and fresh
whereas in dead reckoning you have the
Ensemble is set and that's fine and you
have new blood in Haley Atwell but
there's not really as much else that
feels like it's I don't know the new
distinct thing about this one other than
AI you
know yeah but it it doesn't really do
anything that new with AI no it it does
I I did feel like it's nor does it feel
like I don't know it's a relatable it's
a relatable Fe didn't me for this but we
we should talk about the Marvels yes
let's talk about the Marvels while we're
on this topic yes
um this what I want to okay I don't want
to crap on the Marvels I I feel like the
big headline is about like how it's been
this the biggest comic book movie drop
uh of all time outdoing morbius 79% baby
it's really it is terrible and I think
right now Disney five they are all very
much working their asses off to
re-evaluate the situation in their hands
and I feel like they're kind of doing a
purging of some other stuff sure you
know sometimes we got to do it when
we're like stuck with the show that we
we got to just drop it get out of
the way even though it's affecting our
views and the algorithm drop it all in
one day got to get drop it all every day
for Christmas week I feel like that's
kind of what they're doing right
now yeah I think that's why they're just
like okay even though Marvel's flopped
uh dude okay promote what if uh
drop Echo just drop it just goop and
then then and then we'll have Deadpool 3
and then we'll take a break yeah cuz
Deadpool 3 we'll just cuz I think I
think just having to just focus on
Deadpool 3 is smart because I feel like
that movie will be a billion dollar hit
and I think that'll help re change the
conversation around Marvel and if they
don't go like if they don't get like the
rush you know where they got a taste of
it again and they're like oh let's start
releasing everything again yeah ramp
back up yeah you know if they wait I
think they have to rebuild anticipation
and hype so I don't feel like uh we we
will get to the super just really focus
on this subject right
now the the I think with the with the
Marvel's flopping there are some good
things about it um a I think it's going
to cause mar mar the Marvel Studios to
reevaluate itself I don't like the
conversation that it forms around the
actors and I don't like the conversation
that it forms around Nia Costa there's a
lot of yeah and that was one of
the main things I even in my riew where
I was very upset about the experience I
had with the film I was like I want this
in no way to be reflective of the the
performances here nor NE to Costa
because clearly it is not whatever
negative feelings I have is actually not
about them yeah um like an Costa like
what was the thing going on about the
the the about not getting invited or
some what was that do what
you guys talking about there's a
headline that went up about Nia dasta
Bales and the cast and crew screening
for the Marvels and the very same
article includes information that
basically says like she found out that
the screening existed when she invited
some people to her birthday party and
they said they couldn't go because they
had the screening so you know which
prompted a bunch of chatter on the
internet and and there have been
instances of people basically saying
there's a concerted media effort to
punch down on the Marvels and to throw
you know NE Costa in particular under
the for this sure um and and there are
certain instances of that where it'll
come down to like one word in a headline
and then it's like well you know there
people were comparing this in the Hunger
Games and like how the coverage is
different but the Hunger Games has like
half the budget to make back so like
there are things like that where I'm
like I don't see it as much this thing
with NE Casta bailing on the screening I
do kind of see it because it's there in
the article where they lay out the truth
so I'm like okay this is at very least
Shameless clickbait and at very most you
you know an ATT like these are things
that not everybody is going to take the
time to read and dig further on so a lot
of people are just going to think oh
yeah nasta couldn't be bothered to
finish the movie even though she had uh
you know obligations that cannot be
pushed back forever and ever and ever by
even Marvel um yeah I I feel real bad
for her because it does seem like there
are plenty of aspects of just the movie
in and of itself that maybe aren't
poised to perform as well as they hoped
now but also I think there is some hinky
stuff going on with the public
perception especially of Nea Casta and
it really sucks because I don't think
it's fair all that was a th% what my
worry was when we when we watched this
movie it was 100% what my worry was was
that this movie should not be a
reflection of her Direction because like
I know some people are trying to to at
at the end of the day it does sound like
a spin like yes is is it technically a
fact that this is the biggest performing
movie for a movie that is Hound by a
black female director yeah it is
um at the same time that wasn't the
driving force behind it or nor was it
part of its like promotional marketing
ramp up to entites audiences to go see
this Mo it's a it's an M MCU is the
thing that people are there to go see
Marvel's the thing that there to go see
even NE deosta herself was like I'm
making a Kevin feige movie I'm not
really making a Nia but she said
something along those lines right so yes
there is an accomplishment that she did
get a Helm that however part of the
negative to that is making it seem like
this really was her film when it's not
really her like it's I can't I don't
feel like this is
truly even if you liked it a lot it's
this is not the purest vision of Ana to
Costa film and you're never going to get
that with a big Studio Movie like it's
it's like the closest you'll get that
with is like James gun doing a
movie it's really not the case here well
and he's in a very different position
because as much as I as much as I think
Marvel pulls interesting and inde film
directors with some level of like
genuine like yeah we see something in
your vision and we want to bring that
here I I still think it's a it's a
classic Hollywood move we'll get
somebody who we can bring in here who's
done something of uh some Prestige but
who doesn't have enough swayed to push
back on us when we need to change
around and we're in a stage now where
Marvel is so modular that they
especially with the movies I imagine
always are doing that you know yeah yeah
and I think there's more attention drawn
to
it here's where things
get di I think there's more attention
drawn to it because she is a woman of
course 100% oh if this was just a
mediocre average like it's kind of fun
dude
movie I don't think who directed morbius
uh can you guys who directed morvus guys
couldn't tell you come on can you s me
off the top of your head who directed
morus yeah which was a massive massive
massive flop Jared Leto gets the brunt
of that movie who directed that film
guys sadly yeah and I mean you know it's
so weird to watch Nea Costa's trajectory
because Candyman highest number one you
know opening for a black female director
but Jord got all credit for Jordan Peele
gets the credit for that I mean she got
some but yeah Jordan peele's involved so
he's going to get some of the credit for
that and then this comes out and it's
like you know you have the simultaneous
like highest ever and also lowest and uh
and yeah it is Daniel Espinosa you're
right Daniel esposa there you go but I'm
saying most people won't be able to pull
that you know that off your head
that wasn't really the
conversation around people Wen like
Daniel esposa man he's going to
tank this oh man he he he didn't do the
four he must not care about anything he
must just be an entitled yeah no
it's it's it's not good it's it's a real
bummer khlo Xiao did not get as much
heat because it wasn't as big of a flop
like this is this is a record breaking
FL well and Marvel really backed her up
and it's really on the down like
Marvel's already been on the downward
trajectory uh in terms with Outlets
already been like all right like big
Outlets taking advantage of Marvel's
downward
trajectory and and using it to to boost
themselves so now it's just like all
right what more can we put a stamp on
this like I think AMOM valani the way
her conversation has been around it has
been God that woman she knows what to
say she just continues to prove why
she's so Bob worry about that so
perfect she just continues to even just
not just as Kamal the com that was a man
velot she just like damn you are icing
this
how to handle the conversation
surrounding um how to talk about this
right yeah uh but no I mean I don't
think Nanda Costa is the one to
like it's like when you look at Ryan
Johnson I hope they I hope audiences
give her the chance the way they've
given Ryan Johnson the chance you throw
Ryan Johnson the conversation with Star
Wars it's the Last Jedi but he
still managed to have a great career
after Last Jedi this Knives Out
franchise is a stellar hit it's it's
phenomenal hit and I'm hoping n cost can
generate the same thing don't put her
back in Marvel but I think that you know
what she can with with I thought
Candyman was a really solid was a really
solid soft reboot I thought it was very
very solid and I think she deserves a
chance to prove that she can do
something different and it's not because
but I think I think there is more
attention drawn to it because of the
whole thing with like the women involved
and and it is a huge flop and but
Marvel's already this was just like the
next step it was like this was going to
flop yeah and they didn't they didn't
help I feel like a big difference
between this and the eternals is that
they didn't back this the same way they
didn't help this out the same way you
didn't have Kevin feige out here being
like this is an Oscar winner or some
like comment you know and and eternals
while there was um a lot of female
presence you still had you know John The
Game of Thrones guys and still had uh
Kingo you still had Barry kogan you
still had a lot of people you Tyre Henry
yeah you still had a lot of male
presence as well that was more of like
an ensemble thing and um you know and
and they were still trying something
very different whereas eternals
wasn't a lot of people's negative
association with the Marvels for those
who feel negatively towards the Marvels
not speaking to those who felt
positively towards it I'm not saying if
you feel positively towards it you
should feel different I'm saying for to
Echo this to to to summarize the
sentiments of a lot of people who felt
negative negatively towards the Marvels
is that it was emblematic of all the
things MCU generally has been doing
wrong you know and it's like it's it's
all not the stuff people were freaking
out about in the first movie which which
like they shouldn't have been freaking
out about but it's it's largely not that
stuff whereas
eternals was very much different like
while I I didn't like eternals um it was
not I wouldn't say the problems that I
had with that are the same problems I
have with the Marvels no yeah the the
yeah it's like the the Eternal still
gets to be what it wants to be and
breathe the way it wants to breathe and
this it's like again I was initially
excited for like oh hour and 45 minutes
that's very reasonable and for like the
tone they seem to be setting also very
reasonable then you watch the movie and
I liked the movie more than pretty much
any of the rejects on record here like I
had a pretty good time but it is one of
those things where I watched I was like
this is fun but the fun is hampered by
the fact that I can tell this it just
feels to me like this wants to be a more
breathable movie and a more tonally
finessed movie so that all the fun and
games they want to try make a bit more
sense and uh and those are all things
that just really smack of like retooling
and stuff that yeah it just felt so out
of the creatives control at that point
and uh I don't yeah yeah I mean yeah I
don't think uh yeah bottom somebody
brought a pandemic like somebody brought
pandemic and it's like oh you know is it
always is it even a flop because we live
in a post-pandemic world and you know
it's like everything's going to be 20 C
20% or so less a flop but it's still a
flop because because now in light of
that we're going to have to retool how
much we spend and what we consider you
know for Blockbusters because we're also
at a point now where like these movies
are more expensive than ever definitely
yeah I know we spent a long time there
thank you AOS for that we just really
wanted to uh take advantage of your
question to really really zero in on a
topic there
Michelle thank you
Michelle love your LinkedIn profile
thank you for the plethora of fun live
streams and great content lately oh
thank you thank you for those who have
been watching thank you oh one last
thought Jesus John like dealing with Coy
I think it's unfortunate for Nia D
castes compared to the other director
you mentioned just because uh she Daniel
Espinosa no uh somebody else with more
uh stuff on their plates Ryan Johnson I
don't I think Nia is on a way bigger
back foot right now because now she has
to like deal with all this junk whereas
Ryan Johnson had like a pretty
respectable filmm before he got Star
Wars whereas Nia dasta this is her third
movie and now she's gonna have to
contend with all this nonsense to get
back to a point where Ryan Johnson can
get a new project green lit like anytime
people were excited about Ryan Johnson
Direct in versus Neer like let's see
what she can do yeah you're leveling up
okay you did a pretty good candy man
let's see what you can do yeah the top
of the top at the top you know am thank
you so much for your Super Chat thoughts
on Lex Jimmy and Miss tesm casting who's
playing Miss tesm oh let's find out
let's do this thing James gun has
announced so many castings it's hard to
keep track
sometimes let's
go who's playing here does anyone know
in the chat does somebody know in the
chat chat John Ham Dr Doom definitely
it's going to be
good uh
yeah oh they should get brck testmaker
from uh that would make the most sense
wrestling hey they need to take some
notes from wrestling all right they need
to take some notes across the board from
wrestling guys who's playing her in the
um in in the in the Superman
movie have not seen Sun snakes me we
have talked about Lex and Jimmy we think
they're perfect um for their own variety
of reasons I'm weirdly more excited for
Jimmy than I am for Lex Sarah seio who's
that okay don't know don't know or is it
Seno may I only really know her from
like the portrayals in the in the in the
live action movies I don't really know
the character
honestly oh my God she's hideous she I
cannot stand to look at this woman I
don't hope she has an extended rooll on
screen yes never I hope she never works
again oh she has 8.7 million followers
good be for ugly she is it must be
because lots of people in the world
speak Portuguese what is Sarah s famous
for being a Victorious Secret Angel more
like
the she did some stuff next to K
Blanchet for arm
money uh fragrance Sarah something news
so she caught some of that acting I
don't know I mean people people roll
their eyes at model actors but I'm sure
she's got chops hey hey you know who's a
model actor Charlie theone hey there you
go I'm saying well and I can name more I
think it's funny
it's
good it's going
great yeah
baby okay bab yes I think models turned
actors get a bad rap because how many oh
she was in original creation for the
dawn or Superman why didn't I know that
oh cool that makes sense interesting oh
that's a fun homage then too um so sure
I mean people people slag model actors
but so many actors are probably also
modelings
Palm Clemen F from Mercy
Graves lovely Gary
Gary back in the chat thank you or at
stage so we don't expect her ghost
face oh what a weird can you imagine
what a weirdo if that was the ultimate
reveal what if what if seven what if
Scream s is just the most meta film
where it's dealing with the firing of
Melissa Barrera
and and they don't know whether they're
like how do we they trying to make
another stab movie they just fired the
star for controversial you're taking a
completely different direction you're
doing it still within the scream
Universe I'm saying we step into reality
A New Nightmare do A New Nightmare A New
Nightmare is what I'm saying yes and
then you have uh like it's like the
filmmakers are the stars of the film
they like everyone's just playing a
satirical version of themselves yes and
then bam find out she's ghost face yeah
anyway I like it's not g to happen but
yeah sure why the not that' be cool
and and what a way to set that up by
just completely throwing your studio
under the bus to do it it's a great
comment right here uh I knew a crowd of
models once it was very uh very varied
range of intellect of course it was
absolutely people are not just their job
Jaden Stevens hi Greg and John hey
always a pleasure it is it is it is it
is um sorry it's always a pleasure to
hear from you guys I love the Chanel
your videos have really gotten me
through this year was excited to see
Michael B coming back to direct RE 4
hell yeah thank you for uh Genera guys
in the chat are you excited for Creed
4 forever they got to use it at least
once it would be fitting it's Creed
Creed forever Creed forever would
actually be fitting usually that title
you laugh at and I would still laugh but
I think it's I think it's a very very
fitting title for the Creed franchise
for a character that started off in in
in 1970s with Apollo yeah to now be
carrying this franchise and then if you
are setting
up the daughter to become a
boxer dude it like it's I think it works
it's the perfect amalgamation of the the
heart no I
like this is not an enthusiastic chat
Creed forever Creed forever is perfect
tile I thought this would be way more
positive this chat is like so mixed so
far on the cre thing did you think Rocky
was milking it by four or five I just
you know if we're if we're aligned on
that then that's fine but I think Creed
forever as a title just lovely in a
lovely way combines the heart and cheese
of the rocky Series in general so I'm
with it I mean the Creed movies are way
more serious than the rocky films yeah I
think there's some diminishing returns
maybe just in that like you know we're
in the biggest thick of it with Adonis
and the first one and the second one is
super personal the third one is also
personal but it does have that feeling
of like okay we need to expand this
guy's life out so we can get some more
personal circumstances going you know so
I can see them stretching but I didn't
think it was bad uh yeah I mean and the
big talk about it was Jonathan major who
will definitely be back definitely and
so yeah I think Creed forgotten Creed
for stick Creed for stick uh yeah I I
think that forced sequel what would get
me
excited at the end it is Creed's
franchise Adonis Creed's franchise he's
got to fight Rocky's kid they got to
figure out the whole thing with is it
Irving not Irving kersner Irving Winkler
or who's the producer the one who's in
debacle with Sylvester Salone they got
to figure out that whole yeah
because it is kind of weird when you do
two Creed movies where so much the DNA
is with the rocky franchise and the
mentorship and then we're like we can't
mention him really we can't really even
acknowledge Him yeah and I I think that
they they got to figure out something
honestly bringing back Clubber Lang I
like
it yeah Irvin Winkler it is Irvin
Winkler yeah yeah yeah I think I think
they should I think they should do that
uh they got to figure out um that but I
think Michael B Jordan that was his
first movie he directed and I feel like
he could do an even better job job I
mean I think I already think he did a
great job for first film honestly yeah
clearly studying on set but damn uh yeah
I think I think he would be doing an
even more impeccable job and now like
you can only imagine how much more
expressive and imaginative the guy can
get yeah totally and more how many more
anime flourishes he can pack in there
and I think he can get a I think he can
examine maybe what he could have
prepared for or done a little better
yeah cuz there were things I I I
definitely had gripes with the the
actual I like the first two-thirds a lot
and while the big talk is the big fight
at the at the end yeah I actually
thought it got like extremely rushed
they like they my if my I only saw that
one time but I think my memor Serv me
correct on my emotional Association was
that it they kind of just like slamed
their foot on the acceleration yeah at
some point in the movie and they were
just like we got to get to the
all right we've let this breathe now we
got to wrap it up okay yeah and and I
think um that's a bit of the thing they
got to figure out Bring Back Mr T and
also go listen to asop Rock's new song
about him Tori
Jerry thank you Tori thank you love your
profile pick first time Super Chat I
appreciate all the work you do Barbie
are you oh Don please are you guys
excited for Doctor Who this weekend yes
bet your ass we are as why we're doing
the stream today because we got to cover
Doctor Who this weekend and because we
are caught up on patreon with it um as a
few weeks like month two months ago yeah
uh we were like you know what let's put
this on YouTube yeah it's the first time
we're going to putting it on YouTube and
um I'm very excited for this return
hopefully it pans out well uh to be
doing it for for YouTube because
everything we've done for Doctor Who
just had our patreon we're so we're so
late to it um and this is a new reset
going forward this will be listed as
season one so it's like a new
newo interesting if that's if I'm
reading this correctly you can clarify
thought were doing a couple specials
with tenant they're doing a couple
specials with tenant and then we move on
to uh 14 toti gatwa interesting
interesting so you know we'll see I
don't know is he are they saying season
one because they're going to do some
timey wiy with like the first
doctor or something is that what you
mean timey Wy wibbly wobbly I feel like
any other franchise this would be a
clear sentiment with Doctor Who I'm like
what does it mean they're going to call
it season one these are the three
specials first genocidal tweet from
James Woods what is James Woods is
rarely yeah harmonizing with and then
we'll read the guy then we'll read Kevin
sorbo's tweets I love Kevin Sorbo let's
do it I kind of a soft Saint interesting
well thank you Tori yeah know we are
very excited for it um asop rock is the
king I mean no shade day Sapp Rocky but
for the confusion sake I'll go with you
after the specials it will be season one
oh dude I see okay it is a new a new era
a new area a new I mean they really
changed the lore in the did jod
w which we who we like Jody Whit or we
did we weren't the biggest fans of the
the writing could be better off the
writing and directing man there were
some there were some great episodes
though yeah in the Whitaker I mean a lot
of times it was kind of rough but there
there were times where it was
amazing the the um the the big
major arc they did like at least half of
those were phenomenal yeah one season
where we did the flux was really nice
yeah yeah that was I thought I thought
like half of those were amazing and Jody
killed like she filled the shoes and the
coat all that stuff really well she she
really picked up the Legacy and ran with
it I I think she did a great job and I
don't think we'll be at La ComiCon sadly
J but uh if you go let us know how John
will be there I'm always there I live at
the convention center Jaden Stevens with
Deadpool thank you for the Super Chat my
friend damn Jody's still here I mean uh
omn omn man still here Omni when
somebody said Michael B directing Creed
4 I was like Omni media I was like oh
yeah Jordan Michael B I'm so used to
seeing Michael B Jordan as like one name
hey hey John did dead reckoning with omn
omn man yeah shouts out go go watch us
watch it and I don't know why you don't
ever cosplay as omn man maybe because
he's not not a greaty oh Jaden
Stevens with Deadpool being the only MC
title coming next year do you think it's
more or less pressure on the film of do
well yes uh I I think it
is more or Les I never thought of it in
terms of pressure both um there's a lot
of pressure and I think it also makes a
lot of sense to have it be the only MCU
release next year because I think there
are two sets of stakes it's like there's
the MCU stakes in the sense that like
this got to be good but also there's the
stakes of like Deadpool's coming over
this will be our first taste of like
true anarchic R-rated Marvel uh and I
don't know I think a lot of eyes are
going to be on it because the first
Deadpool obviously is like an iconic
movie A lot of people pretty much love
Deadpool 2 or at least like it a lot so
like the movie itself has to be great
but it also has to be like a
particularly momentous MCU installment
and given that we're gonna have Hugh
Jackman back and we're probably going to
do some kind of crazy meta you know
multi- Studio Universe spanning thing I
think it makes a lot of sense to make it
like the the centerpiece of a year but I
also think that yeah it will have like
so much writing on it from multiple
angles I think I think it helps make it
feel so much more special yeah that it's
only going to be one movie when this
movie should feel special and not just
be another one in the pantheon of MCU
films and for all the movies for it to
be solo yeah this one makes sense and
especially for you know like usually MCU
has been like releasing three movies a
year that to to reduce it down to just
one and to have it be Deadpool 3 I think
that really shines a good spot Spotlight
on it and they could release six
following year to make up for it and
then release a few more shows you know
um I like Deadpool 2 more than the first
one a lot of people don't share that
opinion but I personally I like Deadpool
2 a lot uh I I need to rewatch The X-Men
97 man F I really do because I'm like oh
man I barely remember that show haven't
seen it since I was a kid they keep
talking about it coming back and I'm
like I don't want to be that guy when
I'm watching yeah who's just complaining
like you should make this for people
seen yeah yeah yeah pick up
surprisingly serialized uh Gary um thank
you for being back here my friend it
will really mess people's head if Ghost
Face takes the masks off and says it was
Randy all along well yeah that's
impossible it won't make any
sense break people's
heads every for every movie it's been
Randy yeah yeah no get get Alex aa's
scream and then we can just do a a high
tension again is like this aggressively
makes no sense but it's really intense I
think a scream Trope that needs to die
is how they handle killer reveals it's
always fun figuring out who the Killer
is and being wrong or being right I
always love the game of it it's part of
the fun of every single screen it's like
with saw when you're trying to figure
out what the big twist is do it saw too
um did you like the Twist and saw I
haven't seen saw uh everyone shut up
uh stop stop no don't temp people
oh God
John you know what you just did you
started to I cut myself
off oh God I'm afraid to look oh no just
got to let this die if you see something
you better like Shield me right
away I agree my eyes are my eyes are
locked if you say don't do this you
there was going to be that one
I I don't know what to say right
now I feel like there's something I
could say to set you at ease but I
to much of anything we're dropping the
subject we're dropping the subject you
shut your mouth when you're talking
we're dropping the subject yeah asop
rock is one of the best rappers of all
time if you don't know asop rock check
them out all right mindful solutionism
you have set our friendship back years
joh I have been working so hard to get
it back and it all comes crashing down
today um but yeah if it was Randy all
along I think people would be excited
but it would make any sense here here's
what they need to change about it is I'm
so sick and tired of whenever they do
the killer reveal how they all behave
the exact same they all behave
the same yeah all this like annoying
maniacal personality it's my favorite
try to become Matthew Lillard in that
moment and that the only time it really
worked was Matthew it was him
yeah Matthew have different motivations
or Vibes yeah not everybody has to go
like full on crazy and part of the fun
with that was having Matthew Lillard and
um sko rich rich and they had different
tones to their killer mhm you know one
was like I'm a serious actor like
this your heart robob and your like
wacky anarchic energy guy yeah yeah
exactly so um and but now it's always
like we're both crazy yeah
totally don't mind if I do it's like the
Treehouse of Horror Christian
unpronouncable always one of the first
people who's in our streams first people
comment all the
time um how many celestials do you think
there are four to six according to for
Ty in the age of our universe team would
have been the 13th born so there were 12
others born before him how many were
there originally no there was one
originally there was one and then there
became
more I don't
know that's a koi question I'm sure
there's some kind of like well they had
to have for at the beginning because of
these I'm going to figure this out I'm
going to figure this out hold on a
second let me just copy and paste this
oh bring back officer doofy I think that
would be very fun if they did a
crossover that
way so we're gonna ask uh Google bard
sure let's do that just gonna ask Google
bar what Google bar thinks arishem good
good that you remember the name
there I'm just gon ask Google maybe
exact answer come on Google B in the
movie Eternal zarem the leader of the
celestial tmot was the seventh Celestial
to be born this contradicts the earlier
statement that tmot was the 13th to be
born this discrepancy could be
attributed to a number of factors such
as the vastness of the cosmos and The
Limited knowledge of the eternals
themselves it is also possible that the
celestials do not follow the same order
of birth or that there are multiple
generations of celestials ultimately the
exact number of celestials is unknown
however based on the available
information is likely that there are at
least dozen celestials in existence but
that doesn't really tell us how much
they were original God I barely think
about the celestial SKS and that's part
of the problem with MCU doesn't either
that's part of the problem with the
focus of the MCU before it was just like
focus on one thing Thanos Infinity
Stones and don't because they they they
were going hand inand Thanos and the
Infinity Stones and it was unfolding in
a way that wasn't telegraphing to you so
far in advance that that's what it was
and then they made all these
announcements for phase four through six
and they were like oh all this
stuff is coming and it's all connected
and and yeah all the stuff has been
coming but like so much less than all of
that you know or so much less connected
and and mapped out seeming uh the orig
but appreciate the
inquiry Deadshot did you guys see sawx
and what did you think you better be
careful of Sean uh well I'll give you
guys a quick disclaimer I have not seen
SX yet I was going to their plan
originally was let Aaron and terara
catch up and then the four of us were
going to do it uh all together yeah but
then uh just the timing of everything
and the way this the week was
looking people leaving town it was like
a lot of chaos it was yeah and I I had
to work on other stuff I just plain and
simple had to do a bunch of other things
that day while they got to do the fun
thing I we really miss literally was so
sad I was like chopping away and I just
hear them screaming and like all this
noise and I was like I need to go to
another room I honestly I was I was so
worried you guys like say something as I
still haven't seen the second we cut I
was like guys be be very careful I don't
want anything spoiled yeah but I did uh
I did I did buy it for them so I I own
it as I'm going to like watch it I
absolutely wanted to share that with you
I won't say much of anything um but as a
saw fan for a long time through the ups
and downs uh I it put joy into my heart
and I was very pleased um you know I'm
excited to discuss it but yeah that's
all I say that's I mean the the point
the original plan was before that that's
why I didn't watch in the theaters and
because originally was going to just go
watch in the theaters I've seen like
most of them in the theaters i' I've
definitely seen much all them I've maybe
we have been like two I didn't catch in
the theaters catch was the first this is
definitely the longest I've been without
seeing a Saw movie that's for sure I'm
excited to hear your thoughts um MC no
light thank you so much I just think
norin rad story of serving galatis only
to save his home World Wife specifically
is in Al to the character but I guess
you could say she's wanting to save her
husband I there's so much to that I
think you can a lesbian was riddle me
this was uh was norin Rad's wife like a
really specific big character or was it
just the Classic like I love my wife and
want to save my wife so I'm going to do
this stuff because my wife like I I
don't know I think you know the answer
John you can genderbend that in a way
that works a billion like I don't want
my home world to die I miss my husband
can be whatever I don't I don't think
it's that big of a I don't think gender
really means much to the DNA of the
character yeah that's true it's like
there's nothing that needs him to uh him
or them to be whatever you know yeah
it's not like miles Miles Morales needs
to be uh you know of of mixed ethnicity
because that's who that cares part of
the identity but like you know silver
server can be as long as they're silver
I think it's fine I mean we don't really
know the his like yeah like what what's
the wife's name do we know the wife's
name do we does she have a name what's
the wife's name let me try to find it
let me try to find
it shabal Shala Bal okay he's a
character from his home planet of Zen La
plays a significant role in his
backstory particularly in The Narrative
of why he G serves heral yeah I think
you can swap it with any a FR important
yeah essentially hey Galaxy Geeks thank
you for being here hey thank you for
showing up hey there you go got some
people know the name in the chat Mrs rad
Nicki Minaj silver surface and she's
already in the universe so it makes
sense Carson I mean no I I I think it's
not a big deal if you just make I really
don't this isn't like us being Mr
Progressive over here it I just don't
give a sh like who really gives a
it's more about the demeanor and the
look of the character you could have the
exact same motivation for a it doesn't
have to say they could be another woman
it could be a a a lesbian couple or if
they even call it that the Silver Surfer
is now a big gay family Let It Be who
cares who gives a as long as
they're silver and they're just like
sort of cut like the the quintessential
human specimen I think that's look he
already doesn't have
genitalia yeah just give Silver Surfer a
huge rack yes the the same bald
red no keep the bald head don't even
give her hair if you make it a woman
just bald head with a huge rag yes I
think and and big curvy hips yes a giant
ass yeah like a fertility goddess Silver
Surfer like make it look like the
hottest mannequin you've ever seen
they're going to have to find somebody
who had fit and has a dancer body
probably is whate we talking moap dude
I'm just like if they do make her a
woman make her buff you cowards just
make her buff big boobies one thing I'll
always say for zers like the amazonians
in his themusc are like built and that's
what's up look I don't care what your
opinion is on Zack snd here's what we
know yeah he knows how to capture human
anatomy with this this like oozing awe
that you've never quite seen he would
have like sculpted the craziest David if
he was in that era yeah dud totally the
most admiration the most like e get the
Silver Surfer why not you know it's f it
works I I can kind of even see it it's
the problem I can see naobi Silver
Surfer Carson
hudkins thank you Carson Chris Pratt
Pedro Pascal starring in Scream seven
confirmed I would love
that I don't for some reason I cannot
imagine the two of them in the same
thing but either of them in a scream
Pedro is on the verge though of being
cast in too
much he's he's dancing all over the line
I'm not there I think it's because he's
in big things he's like in the big
franchises and people and just people
love him cuz people were like um
people are like I just feel like it's
he's like the go-to name for everything
I'm like I don't think he is I rarely
hear his name like when you can't say
he's the go-to name for everything when
people were talking about Reed Richards
no one brought upct yeah nobody brought
it yet yeah so you can't and there were
people who were saying like he's just
like the go-to I'm like but's go to for
a type of role now yeah yeah but um and
and but there is a thing where I'm like
okay he's he's in a lot of the big stuff
now and Chris Pratt is not versatile
enough in his voices to be doing all the
voices I got to say that I did preview
that Garfield trailer I was like it fits
but it's not he's just not versatile
enough in the voices you know I this is
the that is what I'll agree with like we
need to dial back some of this Chris
Pratt and every animated thing if it's
only been two I mean he's he's done like
other animated but I'm like two big
ones now we might need to dial that back
a little bit this is the first time in a
long time where I have been like
marveling at how good his people must be
because it's such a meme and yet like
whoever's his booking agent like
must have some kind of crazy Illuminati
skills or a lot of dirt or both on
people because uh because yeah like I'm
like he's I forgot he was Garfield and I
was like this seems like a joke
someone's pulling on me right right I'm
right there with you goat Nation what up
goat Nation greatest of all time he's
saying you guys are amazing you're
amazing you're amazing I'd make a love
to your Super Chat go Nation you're
amazing going to refresh this really
quick to make sure we're not missing
anything don't refresh we should
probably uh we do got other things to
got to do so we could have Thanksgiving
oh my God what Chris you generous
we got to get to that Jesus Christ Chris
God
Christopher Christian Wham off I would
say stop Chris but I'm hoping that there
comes a point where you're gonna just
ask for all of
it I am destitute now I've made a big
mistake chance you still have it mean a
lot would be so fun
yes oh my God it's okay Chris oh now
there's a pressure
we do something for you Chris man holy
can we get your likeness um we need
Zack SNY to to shoot Chris that'll be
the last thing we read is Chris wh
dedicate too much time damn Miss teodora
Miss teodora I recognize your profile
that is masassa from the attack on Titan
finale happy Wednesday my loves excited
for the new Doctor Who AB lutely
we excited for the new doctor can't wait
for it more Tomy Wy wibbly
wobbly reverse the
polarity Alon Alon there you go
terrifier 3 trailer haven't seen it have
you seen any of the terrifi no or
apparently there's terrifi and there's
all through the night there's like a
movie that sets up art the clown and
then there are terrifi and that's like a
Christmas movie so like I'm like maybe
this Christmas movie would be a good
place to start Christmas horror is a
really hard one to crack it is it is
what do we got we got we got Krampus we
got gamlins and we
got uh Black Christmas it's just you
really first time in life oh thank you
so much super thank you damn that's a
chat I just okay Omar oh gonna
have some heavy stuff to talk about but
thank you for joining in for the first
time thank and Christian Jesus go go
check out the Creator it's pretty it's
pretty decent did you see the nasat
tease by Robert Edgar no let's look at
it oh let's see it see all I heard was
he said uh he said like I can't see Bill
Skarsgard like he's just not there in
like he's so in the role that he's just
not there Bill scars guard's playing it
huh yeah I I see it there's so many scar
SCS is it just like
a is it just like a text or is it an
actual photo oh no there an actual photo
golly let's see it what do we got what
do we got what do we got what do we got
come on give me a high res Empire a
channel that has ads on their videos I
get annoyed when I encounter ads myself
very Z about whenever I see an IR I'm
watching an ad on anything independent
that I care to support I'll read cuz
like I think okay ads on a video I'm
just like you have to hit like skip ad
button if you really want to right yes
but like on an article it's like oh what
the how do I get around this thing
yeah so it's it's just his fingers
looming his outstretched hand looming
across the uh the young anu's face damn
a Robert Edgar's NS veratu is going to
be something special yeah boy that seems
like an ideal project because you just
know that that is going to be like I
don't know what they're talking about
they are speaking way too akin to the
time period my soul just feels dark is
there subtitles why is there no
subtitles yeah this is engl oh wow this
is English I guess I still haven't seen
uh the Northman um I've only seen the
witch of his movies actually really yeah
I haven't seen Lighthouse
yet man it's a good movie why'd you
spill your beans terrifier would
definitely be watch this franking I hope
so King Tut on another note thank you
King Tut oh just give us a chance talk
about something I know who would you
rather see come out of Sony spider
versus liveaction movies Scarlet Spider
Ben Riley or Spider-Man 299 uh I think
Spider-Man 2099 part I mean I know
there's a lot of champion right now for
Scarlet
Spider I I feel like Scarlet Spider
wouldn't oh man I'm like so back and
forth in my own brain about it I feel
like Scarlet Spider suits what their
universe is better yes yes uh but I mean
there some it's just I guess it just
depends on the film like for what
Spider-Man films are currently like I
think Spider-Man 2099 for with like
Multiverse and um the kind of like a
more trying to go for like a more
approachable darker approach I think
Spider-Man 2099 kind of makes a little
bit more sense it would be a good tire
tire room where Scarlet spider's a
little bit more something you would kind
of laugh at a little bit right now um
there's a way to make him cool
but in the tandem of things I I'm
assuming the question is coming from
like not not just
adapting the Scarlet Spider Spiderman
like actually pulling them from the
across the spiderverse films and putting
them into live action that's how that's
how I'm reading this question because
you're saying Sony spiderverse I think
it would make 2099 makes more sense to
do that and would be more accessible and
adaptable CU right now Scarlet spider's
a bit just of a one note joke well I
think that's the thing yeah is if you
use if you bring in Spider-Man 2099 that
actually seems like a conscientious
choice because that
establishes I think that would just be
make an easy inroad to have a Ben Riley
then after that you know it just gives
your Multiverse in live action for Sony
a lot more Credence I think if you yeah
and plus you'd have the surprise of like
oh it's it's Oscar Isaac you know
or something like that I don't know if
you do it but you know at least the
recognition of oh damn 2099 is in live
action clearly implies things and then
yeah yeah but that's my take that's my
take but I think Ben Riley if they
weren't planning to do a crossover that
culminates in a Spider-Man 4 or
something if they were just keeping this
like one-offs I would say Bren Ry guys
uh we have uh immensely lost track of
the time we n not us G I think John and
I really needed a live stream today we
needed a loose one we needed like it's
we really needed a like just a fun loose
one today but damn we have really lost
track of time we were just the idea was
just to go from 12 to 2 and I'm like oh
we are so we've just got so and honestly
we've been enjoying our I've really been
enjoying this so much um just being here
and uh it it it's been just to like sit
back a lot like the live streams I I I
enjoyed it's just like having the
conversation has been so fun we're not
going to end right now because we don't
end the stream without cing all of our
super chats and everything like that um
this has been incredibly enjoyable but
we arep another first time soup we are
going to
um uh hit the button in just a couple
minutes to not allow anymore it's got to
be a nicer way of phrasing it to where
you guys cannot be so kind anymore to
gener donate to the super chats but we
want to make sure we read them all off
but yeah man we we've got like several
more hours of things to do and we want
to make sure we can have our
Thanksgiving also sorry I'll Hall zeve
and and art is played by a different guy
so sorry for the misinformation there
terrifier 3 Christmas one damn it is it
no I mean honestly like this has been
really it's been extremely enjoyable
being here like it a lot of times we do
live streams and and I and I just kind
of just wanted to stay here all day so
because they're so fun um oh sir it's
just fun to have the conversation you
know cuz a lot of times when when you're
filming videos you know especially when
I'm like these movie show reactions a
lot of times I'm like so aware that of
the edit mhm and and it's like my mind
has to kind of be simultaneously in two
places at once and I'm aware of like
time all these things so and and uh for
this it's just like ah just let's just
sit back relax and just enjoy a
conversation and spend an obnoxious
amount of time on one question you
know versus versus you know being like
yeah totally to chop chop now
we've gotten carried away we are way now
it's like now now the other we got
to do is going to feel like that we're
[Music]
like this has been so enjoyable MC no
light if super chats aren't working for
you uh you you might well if you're
commenting you've subscribed you're
lying got to bring that as one of the
audios you're Brian Cranson from
Godzilla remember that you're lion yeah
we just need the you're lying yeah that
was like the quote it's the Brian
Cranston impression quote God I
guys I got to say I revisiting
Monarch it's for some reason is making
me go back to the 2014 Godzilla movie I
I genuinely think that movie is severely
underrated his when I rewatched those
films leading into Godzilla V
Kong and got of law I no me that's
Batman B Superman yes I just feel like
it's safe time
sure V yes it does
uh and the explanation Following also
say get a whole syllable back you know
so much you could do with that like
explain taking out the syllable
CA but but 2014 Godzilla is my favorite
of of the monsterverse movies it's the
most of an actual film you know the the
rest of them seem like they're trying to
find out how to be the most marketable
versions of themselves yeah yeah yeah
like I I like I like kol Island I like
um I like uh king of the monsters and I
know 2014's the one but I honestly think
the Pres Shin Godzilla reaction coming
this weekend he hasn't seen it so good
he hasn't seen it but um he's him and
Andrew excited I was like we're doing it
guys doing it it uh yeah and and and to
me I think think
the there's like two ways to capture
Godzilla and I think
the uh capturing from the people's
perspective and the obscurity makes
those moments so rewarding and the fear
of Godzilla and and like you get these
like cathartic moment like that's the
one that gives you that extended Roar
yeah you know where he's just at the
screen and he sees the mut like I love
the out of that 2014 one I really
do I think it's phenom phal just
so much I think it is like like I love
the movie as a whole yeah yeah not just
the last 10 minutes yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah not just like when we finally yeah
yeah I think the movie admittedly I
didn't love it as much the first time I
saw it because I was not prepared for
that yeah but going into it a couple
years later knowing that I was I was
really able to appreciate everything
about it and and I it is my favorite one
of of them all and I'm not trying to be
like cool contrarian opinion guy uh it
is it is just my personally my favorite
one of the films and then I would put
God's love be Kong not versus Kong just
to explain it's not uh versus the actual
title but I say vong to save time of
course yeah yeah yeah no you bought us
so much K
Co Andres good to see you bud Happy
Thanksgiving my friends what movies do
you find yourself watching on
Thanksgiving Matt Colton he already
watched it so uh your your heads up is a
little late uh oh what mov do you find
yourself watching Thanksgiving you know
what I was thinking about this when I
was when I was exercising today
um my mind was saying like if I have
time tomorrow I would love to rewatch
The
Batman I don't know what I don't have
like a go-to Thanksgiving film I don't
have that for this
holiday um maybe kill's the flow I don't
know
I I don't yeah we did talk I I uh I I I
don't have like a um a go-to
Thanksgiving movie but I haven't seen
the Batman on um as I own it on Blu-ray
and I and I haven't seen it on on on on
uh on the nice TV we have I've only I've
only seen it in the theaters but I saw
it in theaters three times so it would
be like it would be kind of cool to sort
of because I feel like sometimes I
appreciate even more at home because
because I can just sort of see the whole
picture easier yeah um and you can
examine in a different way yeah and I
just haven't had that enjoy and and and
no seating experience is going to be
more comfortable than my couch because
honestly three hours in any movie
theater gets a little
uncomfortable uh so yeah I would like to
My Mind Is Telling Me Try to watch that
sure that's a that's a good I feel like
that's a good November movie you know
it's it's very rain it's very gray it's
very dreary of the Season true um I feel
like my answers will all be sort of more
you know kind of ginty than that like
Adam's Family Values is a great one I
think
uh I feel like we often pull out like if
we're if we're like doing the family pie
thing after dinner it's usually like a
classic like Meet Me In St Louis or
something like that I gotta I gotta I
want to watch some of the Thanksgiving
themed horror movies that are out there
uh you know Thanksgiving spy glass
entertainment's Thanksgiving baby just
going to turn up my I go watch that for
a minute I really think that should have
been a uh streaming movie I've heard
it's good I've heard it is and I support
the theatrical release that just seems
like you would have had a better gamble
on streaming it seems like the kind of
thing you would ideally want to do what
they do with the the Halloween or or
Five Nights at Freddy's where you do day
and date so that people at home can
watch it and people who go to the movies
on Thanksgiving can also watch it I mean
you probably wouldn't have as because at
least with those like Halloween and and
five nights you have a an actual chance
of making money at the theaters uh
versus this I feel like most people like
just going on what the is
this let's just watch this home but I
think because of the positive reception
it had I think people would have
actually been like um you know making
Tik toks about it and creating a social
media conversation around it and then
you would have been able to attract a
lot of attention for it
versus I don't know there there's
something that's a really it's a really
Hard Sell like for anything horror
related post Halloween mhm like I'm
talking unless it's like specifically
that like a I'm not talking January I'm
talking
literally Christmas it's a really
hard sell because that's not
what the the kind of movies people are
in the mood for uh November 1 Man people
are like let's get cheery yeah and I
think it's especially stupid when movies
decide to release horror movies like a
few days after Halloween like when they
did that for Overlord like that was one
of the dumbest I'll never forget that
like what an idiotic decision you could
make a whole film festival out of movies
that should have been released for
Halloween season just this year alone
I've heard people lament like Renfield
in the Haunted Mansion probably would
have done a lot better if they put them
out at the time where people wanted to
do a haunted house I don't I I don't
understand the reasoning for a lot for a
lot of these decision makings of like
it's pretty simple guys there's a time
where people are in the mood for spook
spook stuff yeah put it out then go
September the for spooky stuff yeah
don't go in April what are you doing and
especially when um most of you most of
these
theaters they most Studios know that
their best bet are not really going to
be a Barbie when you're going to get all
these crazy repeat viewings odds are
you're going to experience some like 50
to 70% dip your second week that's your
likely Hood so why not just take
advantage of the Halloween season yeah
even if there's more saturation people
are going to be looking for these kinds
of mov exactly put it like end of
September then like get you in the mood
or heck end of August if we're really
stretching but yeah something that looms
Halloween rather than you know is April
it's so stupid or November you know 20th
or something like that cuz yeah I mean
it's a really hard sell this
like even Thanksgiving even if it's like
oh we're doing a a themed you know
holiday it's it's it's tough one there's
still a debate is Night Before Christmas
a Halloween or Christmas movie that's a
November movie to me it's for that's
perfect November the transition perfect
it's perfect yeah like I always want to
stop halfway through whenever I go to
Disney if the it never happens now but
like the times when I've been to
Disneyland in October I'm always a
little bit like I like night before
Christmas but I kind of want the Haunted
Mansion Vibes right now you know like
that's an after Halloween movie yeah and
I think I think um blade releasing in
November is I'm my guys don't do come
on come on I can almost it's like it
should be released in time for Halloween
they should be capitalizing on Halloween
I can see how an action horror movie
might still perform but it's still funky
I think you give your like your a24
horror movies between between January to
June those ones that aren't like yeah
like your talk toies yeah horror movies
you put them there put the cerebral
horror stuff your nopes you know sure
your horror genre splices but then but
then you do your um yeah I know we
really got to go through the chats look
guys I'm sorry I got people are name
checking Planes Trains which you reacted
to you're not going to watch them
Thanksgiving uh yeah I got a um I've
never seen it I got a an I gotta yeah
because we we do have man I'm just
enjoying this if we could just do this
all dayers I guess we could just do this
all day I would I can do this all day I
can I can just live chat all because you
know we have a lot of this allows us to
get a variety of topics out of the it's
fun John excuse me for w to having a
good time talking with people seeing
what everyone has to say I'm the
um no what okay so what were we talking
about John we were talking about guys it
was turning off the this the whoever was
the last Super is the last Super I just
feel like it'd be easier to
do um nothing is easy nothing is easy
everything up to 500% nothing is easy
we're all zoomed okay okay jonath
thought you have the thing right there
where I don't see it scroll down gently
very gently oh it's right there okay my
bad oh I didn't see that there yeah it's
a bit easier then it gives me my threat
yeah are you sure if you continue your
fans will no longer see super chats as a
purchase option and you'll no longer
earn revenue from it ever again until
you slider revenue is
everything buy Pokemon's expensive
cookies to oh yeah get a Mr Beast bar
get some uh got some broke ass
out there what's the Logan Paul drink
what pokon say I was like oh girl I
actually kind of like you man I actually
I actually enjoy you you saying some
tonee right now what did oh no what
did Poké man do something about like
people bitching about her expensive ass
cookies and then made she made a joke
just make you a broke ass broke ass
something and I was like oh girl what'
you say don't slag your young young fans
you're one of those people I'm
progressively having a harder time
admitting I enjoy watching please sure
stop making this hard for me you're not
helping us you're enjoyable I just feel
like girl gamers get a much harder rep
and I have no idea what but uh girls
don't game girls don't ever have a it's
it's the woke left trying to pull one
over on you true true it's good thing we
have the chat in front of us right now
because we don't know what the
they're saying our sarcastic comments at
this moment right um Harry Potter's come
out over Thanksgiving too sometimes John
we must we there is there is
unfortunately a busy day Aisha Kenya
thank we how many people we still have
nine 681 still 681 people that's pretty
awesome on on the day before thanksgiv
yeah Wednesday Thanksgiving afternoon
that's pretty awesome to me man Aisha
Kenya thank you for for chiming in once
again we do appreciate you you hold it
down in she's here all the time I
appreciate you Aisha seriously she's
here all the time yeah and then we do
have some uh super uh streamlabs as well
people can sneak in
some see again RJ we'll get there SL
into the stream M she's saying in this
somewhat um toxic world you two are a
breath of fresh air I'm thankful you
both hey Bonnie I'm thankful you both
exist we love you guys thank you Aisha
you're always here and um you're always
very supportive and positive and I
really really take notice of that even
even if we don't have an opinion you
agree with I know you're always very
respectable so thank you much love to
you thank you we do our best to be the
same it's hard to be non-toxic it's
constant work to be nontox
always lying and we're always worried
that we were secretly terrible so and
yes I will get Andrew to watch in
Tarantino movies on this channel he made
a terribly calculated mistake I'm going
to expose Andrew right now do you
remember when I said in this room you're
watching Kill Bill here yes I
do c c those bastards you just you broke
your pack the blood Covenant son of a
I'm going to kill you I'm going to
rip that mustache right off your face
then I called jabby and I said don't you
dare upload that video and he said what
public uh oh and then I said you're not
coming over for Thanksgiving jabby damn
jabis cabis the
Doomer moment of silence thank you yeah
go listen to some MF Doom
just the rest of the chat I know Doomer
you are already that that blot on your
um the Splat on your jacket is is is is
a uh is something wrong with the camera
nope nope it's just blood you guys are
always super genuine and nice I'd like
to think
so we do our best I'd like to think
sincerity is the name of the game oh
it's cool to be on the background at
work sound off if you're at work and
we're on in the background I haven't
seen succession yet no no no I haven't
but like an
episode oh my life is a constant
dichotomy of me going I wish I had
a camera
poed and then going I wish I could just
do anything without a camera pointed
to yeah man that is the split Coy is in
the chat no handsome Koy is Coy we miss
you we love you sound do a rant in the
chat chat rant Co guys say something
offensive about something and Ki will go
off on you yeah yeah somebody give KY
something to go off about thanks omne
for being here shout out to KY how's
your girlfriend Coy how is your
attractive black girlfriend that you
were dating so that way you don't look
racist this world oh God Jesus Christ no
no we no no we are not feeding this we
should feed it yes we should koi Coy toy
how is your non-racist
relationship sorry ever since that
stream Coy it's going to be the
reoccurring people just existing is
really hard it's going be the
reoccurring joke for me my friend leave
right
now ky's only dated uh good-look
people oh it's really distracting that's
part of the Criterion you know he's he's
like Scientology get ug one in a while
would you and uh yeah and there's
chemistry tests and stuff it's getting
annoying it's getting it's getting
annoying it's looking self-indulgent
eight-legged freaks is the best
spiderverse story ever she's gorgeous no
uh they're both Lucky people weow to say
her name
I she's she's she's gorgeous she is and
she's oh man she is a uh Ko's I don't
know if we're lad her name or not but I
I'll wait for Koy to say wait for
approval and Mrs Koy I think she has a
very grounded personality and I think
she's a perfect balance for the kind of
um eccentricities that Koy brings and uh
I could like she really even like the
because I really liked her a lot when I
met her prior to them becoming
officially boyfriend and
girlfriend and I was extreme I was kind
of um aggressive to Koy
about push I was pushing towards really
like keepy no I was that I was that
attitude about it of like you really
should ask her to be your girlfriend and
you really should like have that
conversation I was very not going to go
into the personal conversations too much
I'm just saying like I I really liked
her a lot so and I was very supportive
and then the the time I saw them for the
first time since being official was on
my birthday and you could just see that
chemistry with them and and the balance
and the acceptance of two very different
personalities where he there is an ease
to them and uh yeah I think she's I
think she's she's a wonderful human
being very creative too and funny and
honest sharp there's a there's a true
there's a true true she reads of
sincerity and um yeah she's great and
more importantly she helps KY not look
racist yes always It's Hard Out Here for
a guy who looks as Neo as Koy does oh
man ever since he shaved his head again
I was like what the do and you're
already a blonde I was like you better
date you better date a non-white woman
Koy to
balance koi we've picked some people
that was the
conversation I didn't want to tell you
guys but that was what it was it's okay
was me being Coy look man you got the
shaved head white boy thing going on you
got to pull the bill bur yeah yeah yeah
you got to pull the bill bur also hey it
would be good if you maybe go out and
like do some charitable work or feed the
Homeless or something just to help your
image really talk about it to help your
image out yeah
[Music]
um this is all responding to any of this
all authentic
genuine koi go I better hide my phone so
my girlfriend doesn't hear any of this
yeah is is she upset now have you just
made an enemy are they're fighting right
now no Pano Gamers feelings on Beast
being CG oh my God no I I hated
that really this was I think the
first time where you were much more
incensed about that than I was I I I
don't love the choice but I wasn't
like no whoa John yeah I would much
prefer a practical Beast we have like 48
movies of Beast being practical yeah no
I agree you don't just go but
it's exactly what the MCU would do it
it's exactly what they would do I'm not
giving it a pass I don't I I don't know
I don't care how old Kelsey Grammar is
you put that old ass Republican in that
blue makeup all right I mean sure again
I'm not going to argue too hard against
a practical effect uh you know I don't
and I don't know the thing is part of me
is curious because I'm like I don't know
if we're there but like the thing is
like if we're there and it looks great
then fine but you know I don't know if
we're there yeah yeah no I don't I don't
I'm not a fan of it um I think it's very
distracting and it pulls me out of the
believability of it is this going to be
fun Jos that's part of the awe that's
part of the awe to it when you see beast
in in Practical effects I don't I don't
even care if at first you're like oh it
looks a little weird because you get
used to it and and then it feels
realistic it's
there part of it of the realism is Beast
doesn't want to look like a
beast like he doesn't want to look that
way and he's had to he's try he's had to
accept himself as a mutant and part of
that is to have that effect when you
first see see him and and and you're
like oh it looks a little weird but
because you want to you want to react
that way and to have that tangibility
that believability and makeup where
you're like oh that's odd I think that's
important yeah I do I do think I think
it's important and especially if you're
going to it it it's important to me
especially if you are carrying over a
character portrayal that is pre-existing
if you're doing a brand new take if
you're doing a brand new take like
Seattle's pointing out in the chat Groot
Hulk Thanos all brand new for the MCU
even Hulk PRI and the Ang Le CGI they
did not do practical but if you are
bringing over Kelsey Grammar beast from
the X-Men movies who has been practical
then you should be giving I I will fight
to the death that that should be
practical effect that makes sense I
agree
all right all right come here buddy come
here copper let's get this going come
here I know you're hungry I'm hungry too
I did not eat like a dumbass um John
stay from Joshua we're very Palestine
interesting you chose to do a live on
this so that also condemning the
terrorist attack on October 7th thanks a
lot John yeah this is my fault uh I
would love to know what the rest of the
sentence that I said just trying to bait
into getting a super chat here yeah uh
yeah follow up with the end of that
sentence so I know exactly how to
respond to this um of course
I uh what do you mean like I didn't I
say before we went live I said you been
be careful about how cuz everyone's
going to pinpoint everything we say I
know they're going to find a way or
didn't say or didn't say uh I mean what
what what else can I say uh of course I
condemn of course I condemn a terrorist
attack I condemn want and violence I I I
recognize that the attack Haack itself
exists in a much greater Continuum than
I am well versed in so I understand that
there's like a greater context happening
than just the isolated moment but I've
yeah like do I wish it was everything
that day had been different and a bunch
of people didn't die and this whole
conflict didn't get you know completely
reg galvanized and and recalibrated like
yeah I do I would love to live on that
timeline I absolutely am not pleased it
just seems like the way you talk about
everything else yes that as I would be I
would be for this I would be the kind of
guy who would be
like is it would be lost in the massacre
whoever you want to for for whatever
purpose really that that was the problem
John is it seemed it got confusing to me
because I was wow sorry guy I didn't
mean to give you the impression that I
love
terrorism uh no I like I don't know I I
still just want to know what the
sentence I said was did I say we're very
pal
yeah I agree with wan to in the chat um
uh yeah like um everything is John's
fall why hasn't he condem every single
bad thing that has ever happened in
public yeah I need to be on Twitter
always being like you know because I am
not the expert to hearing nobody needs
my thoughts on this because I am just
forming them but uh but yeah the easiest
way for me is to say it is like if you
don't it's one thing
to condemning the acts of a of of of
government is one thing and then or like
condemning the acts of government is one
thing but then to take it out on people
just just people in general the innocent
people whether you're Israeli or
Palestinian is the thing that we can
confidently
state that we do not support that side
of it at all like like we can go into a
whole debate forever which we're not
going to do refuse to you know right now
you can say whatever you want in the
chat we're not going to um it is the
idea that like people who are suffering
for things that they should not be
suffering for they just like people
living their lives and people
who are embroiled in a conflict that not
everybody's on board for like the the
most challenging aspect of this has
being you know learning how to hold two
ideas in mind that that you know wanting
violence and loss of life is bad but
also people who feel intensely oppressed
will go to Extreme Measures to break
that cycle of Oppression and it usually
takes really harsh action to do that and
I don't know what to do with that
morally you know um this whole situation
has sort of forced us to sit here and
and kind of hold two ideas that really
conflict in mind and sort of try and
come up with an answer that people
haven't been able to for so much time
now like I just don't understand how I I
feel like this video is already
demontage so it um but I'll be I'll
be
up so much of like there's I'm always
asking questions I'm always trying to
have conversations so I could just keep
learning keep learning keep learning you
know and I try to get both sides I I I
really do I try to like people who are
willing to just actually have a
conversation with me to like kind of
push back on something when I question
something you know that's just not going
to happen here on the stream it won't
it's not gonna happen here we could
solve this today like it's not gonna
happen with like someone's typing
something to me no
um
and I I I just want when I see when I
see stuff of like all these children in
like Gaza especially you know as of late
of of when you're watching like these
raw videos of what's happening
to children out there I'm like I have
the hardest time not one part of me can
get on board with like you just you just
watch it like there's got to be another
way there's got to be got to be there's
got to be another way like so much of
Gaza is made up of children and when you
see what's happening to them it does
feel like the sentiments that Melissa is
expressing yeah you're just like God
these people
are they are suffering at
the I'm not going to Deep dive into it
I'm just saying that right now like you
can't I'm not I don't if you just take
time like 15 20 minutes you watching
videos of what's happening to them like
the actual Raw videos whatever ounce of
UNC comfortability you feel will not
equal an atom of of discomfort that they
are feeling over there it is truly
horrendous what is happening to them I
saw somebody the other day put it as
like your discomfort is is their entire
reality right now every waking moment
yeah you know yeah and I get PE like I
like you could ask Chris swam off you
know like I try to find like it's it's
so hard to find so yeah like what
happened on October 7th terrible what
like I don't agree with like a
killing innocent Jews I like Jew
shouldn't be Jewish people should should
be getting killed for it I think
you can you can kind of arrive at this
like I am Pro you know the the the real
like the regular people the real people
just trying to live life the Jews uh the
Arabs you know the Palestinians the the
the Israelis who were just trying to
live life and have a place to be safe
they should both have that but I'm also
you can do that and also kind of be like
the idea and Hamas are
both
problematic to put it so very lightly
like yeah it's uh yeah neither of these
groups of people it's it's the sad thing
if you have these two Waring go like
governing factions that are so different
from the people that they should be and
kind of are fighting for but I think
it's kind of even beyond that and now
you know we we're getting into territory
that I don't feel really comfortable
commenting on I me it's like to say that
like yeah of course we want people of
Palestine to be free but we condemn the
actions of Hamas and then then some
people will like poke holes and some
things of us saying that right and at
the end day I'm like of course I want
why would I not want people to have
their freedom well yeah and of all the
arguments to have this is I'm sorry like
I'm not sorry I'm not I'm not gonna say
I'm sorry I'm just saying that like it
is it's it's a lot yeah it's a lot and
and uh yeah it's complex it's ever
changing in the thick of it right now
and it's one of those things that is not
there's there's not as easily defined
you know again when it comes to like
sexual misconduct or racism or sexism in
in the public sphere there are more
strong identifiers to you can find the
right opinion to have I feel like for
the most part whereas with this
situation it's almost impossible to come
to an arrive in an opinion or a take or
or an assessment that everyone will
agree like no matter where where you
land there's going to be a bunch of
people who vehemently disagree with you
no matter how you know based your take
might
be% yeah and that's the hard part of
this and it's the hard part of seeing
decisions like this with uh Melissa
Barrera because we're like this is Super
Fresh and it's ongoing and it's only re
reignited something that has been going
on for decades and beyond that uh and I
just feel like she was so clear
though in clear and she was to compion
condemning the actions of the of
the government stuff that she disagrees
with but not condemning people she's not
condemning Jewish people she's not
condemning you know like and she takes
great time separate explicit about that
the IDF is not all Jewish people and
Hamas is not all Palestinian people and
a lot of Palestinians don't love Hamas
and a lot of Jew a lot of Jewish
Israelis don't loveah don't like like
they want Palestinian Freedom too like
yeah you can hold a bunch of ideas in
mind at once and I and I yeah and and I
don't know like the the category they
lumped her into is it's just like wow
what a bunch of yeah and I'm
not I'm never the kind of guy to be like
I okay never mind all right I want to
move on I do I I want to move on I want
to move I want to move on I do I per I
want to move on all
right so Su my Nicholas hold
he's great yeah J he's great let's talk
about inconsequential stuff by
comparison no to crate but I was rooting
for Alexander scars guard as
Lex yes I what copper come here buddy
I'm sorry I know we were getting
agitated
Cito I I like to think that my cat comes
here when he sees I'm act agitated but
then I look at the time and I go he just
wants food no he knows you're agitated
come your copper I I
think and he'll do great but I was for I
mean I think again Alexander scars guard
is kind of a really obvious pick and I'm
I want to be pushing against the grain
of things sometimes an obvious pick is
like
oh my favorite kind of obvious picks are
like oh yeah why didn't I think of that
yeah you know that guy would be perfect
like Jeffrey Wright as commissioner Gord
yeah you're just like I wouldn't have
thought of that but that great yeah yeah
yeah that that's perfect you know like I
don't know why that seems so
obvious but yes it works you know like
that's a that's a perfect one Gia I
about Alexander scars gar for
Lex I think Nicholas then again I would
have been fine with Brian Cranston
honestly that was the one where I I that
was the one of the ones where I was less
Enchanted where I was like ah I I know
he can do this you know it would be fun
but I wouldn't be like dazzled at the
thought of it
yeah but you know you know I think
Nicholas Hol matches the age like I
don't without knowing the actual ages of
Alexander Skarsgard and Nicholas Hull I
just feel like he fits the the youthful
cast to me of what James gun seems to be
putting together a bit better um but
that's just me that's me too Abra in uh
Captain America 4 um is not the hummus
that you
buy uh nope but you know doesn't she
have she has Israeli flag and stuff hell
yeah
interesting hell yeah let's get uh Roxy
strier Andrew Gordon or Michael
tesler Marvel vows new approach to the
character oh golly oh golly oh
golly oh no I don't know what to to to
make of this John say something that
won't get you in trouble oh sure I think
this is a great idea and whatever they
do to retool this character will be a
okay by
everyone I didn't know that this
character existed until just now and uh
yeah she's that I'm starting to realize
the inherent second wait Marvel's issued
a statement on
them is this actually oh my God this is
a real she's really in this oh my uh and
is really superhero oh oh what's the
statement while our characters and
stories are inspired by the comics they
will always be freshly imagined for the
screen in today's audience and the
filmmakers are taking a new approach
with the character Sabra who was first
introduced in the comics over 40 years
ago oh my see this when did they
announce I don't we don't know anything
about her back story and stuff all I'm
seeing is like the image of being a
proud Israeli so I don't really know
exactly what the you know what what back
yeah what that turns into plot-wise I
don't know anything about our character
it mostly makes me wonder I can't
remember when they pushed the movie and
now I want to know because now I'm like
are they now did they push the movie
because of the conflict that is sa is
gonna be like Zea and NCIS working for
the USA but it's Jewish okay Zea shouts
out cot dep Pablo um yeah yeah yeah uh
it'll be interesting I mean part of me
just wonders if this seems like any
Marvel tries to do anything vaguely
sociopolitical post Winter Soldier like
stuff in the world gets too real and
they have to retool it all so I'm like
did this happen here you it certainly
must be
now all right right John John we're back
at it Joshua a accountability nothing
God damn it John what did you say
earlier in this chat to upset our Joshua
a guy
so he would have to get in here and then
even Super Chat to get your attention
I mean you're not
wrong using citizens as human Shields is
deplorable and is like a totally Twisted
way to advance your cause absolutely
yeah no one's debating that no one's
debating it I I think I think we
answered extensively I think we would
all rather be in the cold version of
this war certainly like or not in this
conflict at all but like um let's see
Mustafa jof I've had a shitty last two
months
after losing my job and a girl that I
thought loved me oh I'm sorry I've been
there
man I've been there sending feeli send
in love for you we we'll each give you a
hug we'll hug the camera and you can
transfer that onto you we do need a CO
we needed a koi it's uh no man
dealing with
um koi can handle this
topic I mean yeah it's not like it's not
like any of the three of us are really
in authority on this topic we're all
learning day by day by piece by
piece your videos got me through it all
since I got a new job I want to share
some love you're my Matthew Perry a that
comment it is gonna make me cry
don't say
that damn a dude oh no I'm getting I'm
getting watery you son of a could
you be you could you be
any more of a shining light in my that's
really touching that is a
I did not expect to hear I like it I
love it thank you that girl man
whoever that girl was scre man she
doesn't know what she's missing she
busted bro and that job you don't need
that job freaking ugly
man
God if ever there was a set of
sentiments that whenever it's given me
I'm always like thank you for the intent
but also I don't I don't need these S I
didn't even like her man no one liked
her like no this isn't helping
this is just making everything weirder
and worse and now I'm not going to trust
you the next relation if I get into yeah
yeah oh my God that's really sweet thank
you well I'm sorry you're going through
some pain right now but that pain
allowed you to make me feel really good
so the more pain you feel the better I
feel that's uh that's I I am a I'm a
sadist like that I'm a masochist but no
that mean I like hurting myself yes
what's the word sadus mean I like to D
pleasure from your pain you enjoy that
shot in Freud
yeah so Kevin Meek Kevin Meek man very
generous Super Chat we haven't
even got to the massive massive massive
one this is a really big one thank you
my friend thank you oh this has
been a very uh fascinating stream sure
enough John and I thought we'd be H it
and quitted today yeah we thought this
would be
slow but no we come for the real no
man thank you um um thank you that is
very very kind um oh never catch
youall live just want to say thanks
y'all help more than you can know
appreciate you guys thank you Kevin Meek
thank you we appreciate you know what to
come in here you be holding it down such
a generous like super chat comes
in dance and then and then you know and
they don't give us something to answer
and I'm like flex your Bice what do I
say that is so different to stand out to
show my appreciation for such a generous
Super Chat do like a peck dance John is
definitely the
Ross sure th% isn't no friends well
enough to know but you're definitely the
David frommer I could see it no I mean
if I'm not Chandler and I I I mean
Joey's funny but I don't want to be Joey
so no one wants to be Joey yeah you
don't want you want to know Joey you
want to be
Joey so oh but but no but Stephen
disagrees I guess I am at everyone say
John is
Jo that's good I I guess I guess on
camera Joey I've ever heard of yes smart
at some things Kevin that is a very very
kind Super Chat thank you Kevin thank
you Kevin we love you we love seeing
your name pop up Robo
96 have you guys seen socks John I'm
sorry do you want a piece of cheese sure
I'm gonna get a string cheese uh you
answer this question question you go get
a piece of cheese I'll keep it
short yes uh
yes uh Greg has not seen it be
respectful uh and I and I mean that
because I was truly truly truly truly
bummed uh that we didn't all get to
watch it I wanted to share that
experience with like me and Greg share a
love of saw that uh you know I think a
lot of people I was a barista in fact uh
I think a lot of people you know
don't love jigsaw and his various
teachings as much as Greg and I do so uh
so yes um I I really really really
really liked saw 10 sawx uh I was very
as a saw fan I was pleased my heart felt
full uh it felt very special and like a
very lovely culmination and I feel like
you know if you wanted to end it now you
know you don't have to but you could and
I would be like content um yeah I I
really liked what they did with it I
really liked uh how they conceived it um
and just yeah like the the pitch the
tone all that stuff um good Ensemble of
you know it's it's a it's probably like
the best made film of all the saws so
very much uh part of me is like bring on
more but part of me is also like we're
good all right I'm holding the bread I'm
holding the bread I'm holding the bread
we doing this this is one of my um
random Rush snacks oh I get you I get
you what you gonna do just crunch cheese
into you're making like a poor man's
cheese tequito right now it's keto bread
so it's only like 30 calories no sugar
added hey low carb she's
toeto so here you go that one thanks
I'll have
that hey you know we live in America
where the ugly food gets discarded but
I'll eat it yeah no it's just as good
it's just as good now the keto Bread's
great hey Connie Happy Thanksgiving
Connie hostile is not better than
thought well maybe maybe like no what
are we on we're on
seon do you guys have any concerns for
Superman Legacy with the
being announced feel like a Superman
[Music]
movie
mother sorry somehow my mouth got Fuller
as that went on do you guys have any
concerns for Superman Legacy with the
amount of characters being announced it
doesn't really feel like a Superman
movie anymore maybe it's too early to
tell love yall um I think for the
average audience it might feel that way
um but I mean you've read
pound-for-pound more comics than I have
having seen all these DC animated movies
I don't know I just feel like it's
normal in
comics to have a like broadly populated
world where you have a lot of
superheroes who already exist you have a
lot of powered people who already exist
new fetish unlocked I like it um yeah I
I think it's a lot more commonplace in
the actual medium that these are all
coming out of to have like a whole bunch
of people and and other characters like
that is my Rocky impersonation I can't
do it without this specific snack um but
but I also understand your concern at
the same time like it is a first in a
rebooted franchise and all that stuff
but I I think that'll partly serve as a
primer for people to understand that
this will be a much more broadly
populated world and a lot less of just
like oh whoever's the name of the movie
is like one of either the only powered
or one of like a couple powered people
in this movie you know what I mean let
me
uh in tell some about Jam James gun this
is a mukbang now not many people know
how to
deliver a debut Ensemble the way James
gun knows how to do here here and we've
seen him do it where it's like a we
got to make like 14 superheroes front
and center in one
movie I don't know if it'll work oh
he pulled it off yeah we're just talking
about like you know a villain a
hero a
Lois well like these aren't most of them
we we know we just need one of them to
be front and center which is Superman
yeah and the rest are supporting
characters it's not a big deal yeah yeah
yeah it's not I I don't feel like it's a
lot he's just he's just building the
world of it Matt Colton say mainly to
introduce the authority which I could
see but yeah I mean a lot of the casting
are characters too who are just like
normal people
characters but you know Rando Mano thank
you Jack Quaid is in an awkward position
support his Israeli friend T Capone
Frenchie or is co-star Melissa barer I
mean you could support your friends I
mean I haven't I I be care I know to Mar
Capone has been pretty vocal I don't
know actually what the tone is of what
he's been saying I think Jack Quaid
should just be as compassionate as
possible toward I mean like that's a
real thing you're going to have two
people with different ties and I mean
especially toer cap being from Israel
you know you're going to have people
with different ties and I certainly hope
that this doesn't mean the end of
friendships it may for some people and
that's part of the that's part of the
tricky part of all this you know I've
seen it
happen yeah I I mean we know some Jewish
people I've seen it happen yep so I
don't just do your best to to listen but
if you're able to have a conversation
and know what lines you can have about
where you can disagree and if it's okay
that you disagree on this
thing um about certain things then then
you're fine but some people are just
like nope All or
Nothing Chita back in the chat Gia
three years she's been here be her best
friend you think I forgot about that it
was like an hour and a half ago I didn't
forget about
that it's okay it's okay this this one's
all about how great you
are I honest always saying Philadelphia
the oldfashioned way I paid them money I
begged and cried and eventually they
said if you've got the J give you $2,000
me I'll give you more than I would have
gotten
paid do you think we Marvel fans have
unrealistic expectations of them to
continue to create lightning in a bottle
like they did with Iron Man in Phase One
how did they tell stories moving forward
uh I don't I feel like the expectations
are not as high as they want
were the the comment that I don't
like a a com a common
comment that I really don't like and
maybe there are the people out there who
do need to hear it is not everything
needs to be
endgame I don't ask for that ever like I
never ask for that I and I i' I've had
that dish my way many times I would love
a standalone that doesn't need to be all
of the stakes poor foror please I mean I
understand and endgame is a culmination
thing of like a billion movies and of
course not everything needs to be
endgame uh nor does it need to be the
quality or the hype level of
endgame and in retrospect you know I I I
I don't know what my favorite MCU movie
is anymore I I really don't like I went
back and I I randomly re-watched
Infinity War an endgame I can't remember
if there was like a a purpose to it or I
just randomly put it on uh
and and uh I think it was just like I
was I randomly put on Infinity war and
then I was like I guess I'm here I was
watched and I put on G after and
uh and and I think I liked Infinity War
more
um how I would summarize my experience
with infinity war and endgame is I think
Infinity war
is possibly the best event comic book
movie and I think endgame is the best
MCU movie or the best representation of
it's the quintessence of of like what
the MCU is rewards but I don't know if
it's my favorite anymore as just a movie
there was a time where I said it but
then like now the after some distance
and then watching it on Disney plus I
like there's things about the lighting
that
really I feel the flat ways it's shot
sure and before I didn't quite feel that
or see that um well and I think favorite
also implies like a
rewatchability and and like an
enthusiasm to put this on where like I
don't I end game's like you know I'm not
going to debate the status and the
greatness of the things endgame achieves
but like rare is the occasion I'm like I
really want to just hang out and watch
endgame well you
see Iron Man is still a great movie and
because it's not doing all the the only
thing that people maybe have an issue
with to this day in terms of of a film
is like ah you kind of get a Villain at
the end who just
becomes you know a bigger Iron Man but
think everything leading up to that Jeff
Bridges is a pretty impactful performer
in that film yeah I like him in that you
know as OB stain I think he's a pretty
impactful villain yeah he's he showed up
while
predictable I think everything about it
is still it's well paced it's well
written for a film that was surprisingly
being written kind of on the Fly it's
well written the acting is is wonderful
it feels like composed intentionally
shot where now it just does kind of feel
like we're putting things in a factory
and in an algorithm that that common
thing you you hear people saying feel
like an AI made this is because things
are starting to feel a little bit like
algorithmically made even if it's fun
well it feels too big now to take its
time ever it's like like the thing is
now it feels like fast food whereas
before it kind of felt like a rest a
restaurant where you paid for a good
meal and now it's like you can get a
burger at like a fancy restaurant or you
can go to McDonald's and and now it's
it's not quite McDonald's but it's the
rebranding when when all the fast food
joints like McDonald's or Burger King or
whoever else rebranded all their menus
to be like look at our artisanally
sourced lettuce tomatoes and when
you're like this is a still at
McDonald's yeah yeah yes that's a great
way to put it um uh I don't think
they're unrealistic expect I mean for
some people yes but I don't think
they're unrealistic expectations like
yeah it's hard to catch lightning in a
bottle but I don't think a lot of the
problems are about that so much I think
you could still get very good material
instead of mediocre material without
having to catch lightning in a bottle
necessarily I think it is to me the
biggest culprit is the modularity is
just that they plan so far in advance
now and they make everything to be
remade and retooled that you just cannot
put a certain level of distinct
personality into any of these scripts
otherwise it's going to become a problem
I I was I I was actually listening to uh
I watched I watched uh film theories
latest video which we had a little cameo
apparently I didn't know this it was a
fun moment no one told me the film
Theory and and I think their latest
video really breaks down the the problem
best better than we could say if
anything I if you guys haven't seen it
um even if youve really enjoying the MCU
I think I think that one really um
breaks down in a very efficient way
while being incredibly
informative uh jihas Sara how does super
thank you so much my friend how does
Super Superman avoid the two powerful
argument you give him a more powerful
villain yes Captain Marvel gets killed
for having no real Stakes leading a
boredom when Superman is just as
powerful if not more is it just
Nostalgia no I mean it's the human life
he's trying to balance against all this
yeah it's the
um the
power no
please I think you should it's the power
it's it's it's the uh illustration of
choice that I I think makes it
challenging I mean if if you look at the
first Superman with the whole
you know turning back to clock on Earth
it was like where do I go save like how
do I save Lois there's that there's also
um
the yeah you can just give him a more
powerful villain or an equally powerful
one you give him Zod you can give him a
brainiac I think Lex both I think Lex is
um a compelling one because you are
dealing with the most powerful being
versing a very superiorly intelligent
person there's but you see Captain
Marvel doesn't have a
Kryptonite that's that's like a saying
right what's the Kryptonite that's a
saying but for Superman that's his
actual physical enemy gave us the term
yeah that gave us the term and I think
um that's the other thing is like well
that's also one of the balances is like
we know what his weakness is that
motherfucker's got Kryptonite you know I
mean as as as I've learned from you know
various you know through the animated
stuff especially and and I think my
adventures with Superman was a great uh
uh illustration of this as well and and
you know I think KY I've certainly heard
Koy say this a billion times the
struggle of Superman is you can't save
everybody you can't be everywhere at
once no matter how powered you are and
yeah I think those are enough Stakes you
know and and and and larger than that
how do you remain the good good hearted
person that Clark is in a world that is
as harsh and brutal as this one is as
well and I think James gun is probably
in a good position to give us that
wholesomeness and then Clash it with the
rude awakening of actual you know malice
and and atrocity blah blah true very
true so yeah it doesn't have to be all
saving cats from trees You Marvin Martin
good name Marvin Martin the Martian
literation do you think there's a house
of cards thing behind the scenes to
script Hollywood Twitter etc for some
hidden alterior agenda I hope so now I
like this
conspiracy uh I don't I I don't think
that Twitter and Hollywood are like
somehow Hollywood hates Twitter and
Twitter is its own you know Cesspool
septic tank now and uh you know it's
it's it's clearly an autonomous entity
that's imploding and exploding so I
don't know I mean Hollywood is a
trickier House of Cards it's a funny
thing like with social media and
Hollywood because social media YouTube
being part of that um has changed the
game of marketing forever you know for
for Hollywood and like where they use
trailers they use influencers they're
getting actors on social media
platforms to promote their uh
creating I don't know weird adventure
games to go along with people
yep you know uh like they do a bunch of
crazy stuff it forever changed
marketing and yeah those kinds of things
used to be novel and now they're like
the norm oh yeah man remember there's a
time where you be like I to go there
early to catch this trailer yeah I want
to see the trailers oh my God now I go
to the theaters and everyone's
showing up with the movies like like
already started people can time it so
like I want to arrive just when the AMC
or whatever movie theater I'm in bumper
ends movies because everyone's already
seen the trailers excluding if they got
word that no one's debuting this trailer
that hasn't been out yet you know and
he's not going to put it online yeah
yeah so there was a time where even that
was special but now it's like get like
14 trailers and there you get like just
look at the look at the Marvels look at
any Marvel movie you get like three main
trailers you get like a bunch of TV
spots and where do you watch them all
you watch them all on the internet yeah
you know you rarely see them in the
theaters now and if you do it's because
you got to the theater
early because before you had to like
reserve seating wasn't a thing it was
that was like it became a rare thing for
theaters and now there's this sh you
know like they yeah they need it is a
weird thing but at the same time social
media is every is the Hollywood's
biggest threat you know it is and and
and I mean it really must hamper like
all these movies and things take so long
to make and it must hamper a lot of that
long
Ops yeah and then you have actors who
are now can give their opin you know
like before I think there less
constraints in place to like keep all
these things from overflowing whereas
now everything's kind of been
redemocratization
one of my my dad's best friend a family
friend of ours uh is a man you guys
might not know his name anymore some of
you guys might recognize his name Ed
Asner Ed Asner is you might best know
him as either Santa from Elf or uh car
Carl from up or you saw him recently on
COBRA Kai or yeah he was Johnny
Lawrence's dad on COBRA Kai prior to
this he is one of the actors with one of
some of the the most he might be like he
might be top actually most Golden Globes
ever for male actor sure um so yeah he's
he's Prestige actor and a lot of his
career was immensely
damaged severely
damaged
because and I've never and I had never
talked to Ed Asner directly about this
but it's just a it was just it's a known
fact about what happened with his
career he was an activist
and as much as he played like these K
tiners people he's like grumpy cranky
tough as Nails mother effers yeah he's
he had a mass even in person like he
he's just like that that blunt human
being you know like I get intimidated
being around him even though I was like
around him so much but he is an activist
for all the things he's a liberal
activist and that was not
popular
when he was be when he was famous he
really wasn't and it
completely completely damaged the man's
career for such an extended period of
time made it really difficult for him to
get work got fired as Luke Grant show
which he won Golding gloves for can it's
the whole thing and at the end of the
day you look back and you're like oh he
was on the right side of History yeah
you know yeah but at the time wasn't
exactly popular opinion you know yeah
and those tides are always moving and
shifting yeah in terms of yeah what is
acceptably uh what is acceptable descent
I guess yeah yeah
totally know that about it that's
inspiring yeah I mean it really it
really that's the reason why
it he didn't maintain the the fame that
he that he had you know um but he was he
was like a superstar for a while oh yeah
he's he's a super prolific even still
but I'm definitely not reading that
message in virro Earth to two things in
the chat one rocket it's not a cont AMC
absolutely cowards for not letting the
jigsaw Billy puppet Nicole Kidman thing
play absolute uh two Janine
posited that MCU is actually Chipotle
chat do you
agree par blind wave collaboration
anytime soon we are blind I'm the guy
from blind wave and I am Eric yeah you
just look really different under these
lights
he's that guy I'm that guy who people
like are you that guy from blind wave
yes that's happened in
person that happened at what was that
VidCon yeah was it VidCon someone came
up to you and they were like so it was
the funniest thing guy is full as I
just got to call it out the guy went up
to me's like real reject like to me he
went real rejects I'm such a big fan and
then he turned to you and he
said
blind like you're not a you're not a
real must not be that big fan you can't
know me not no John he only watched
straight to the point and made sure to
be exposed to nothing
else yeah that's why that's the joke
with Jon of going hey the the blind wave
guy yep yep yep Jerry Shane
yeah dead shot will you will you guys do
a separate reaction for San I mean John
already joined Tara and Aaron for it um
yeah but I appreciate the the inquiry
though you can do your own solo reaction
and we'll just Stitch it into we'll
superimpose it over our reaction Omar
elcott Omar I wish my first Super Chat
was about something else oh no Amy
Schumer posted a picture calling gin
that's I want to say that word on stream
yes calling gin's rart while Melissa is
the one that got fired without saying
anything anti-semitic big fan of you
guys
lot is that is um one of
the uh unfair Assessments in
the the culture of all this yeah yeah
yeah that is I didn't did she really say
that I actually didn't know that she
must have because I've throughout this
and I haven't dug really deep on it but
I've heard Amy Schumer's name come up a
lot and usually not yeah let me say what
let me see what she said oh my oh my
what do we got what do we got her
Instagram posts received more than
87,000
likes since since deleted comic on
Instagram attended to saiz comments made
by damn that is some horrible to
say
wowe oh man oh and she wasn't like like
being ironic or some ill attempted humor
or I mean she wasn't caned for that
I mean I guess what does she have to be
canned from at the moment oh she
actually did she that is worse than what
you put in the Super Chat
yeah that's that's not that's not good
everyone's bringing up Noah schnap this
whole time yeah which Noah schnap part
of me is like I don't know you're a
young kid you're you're still kind of a
kid so like not good but also like
I imagine you may have some learning
coming your way where it's like Amy sh
is in a very different position and at
least doesn't have as good of an excuse
to be ill informed Jesus Christ um yeah
oh
boy well I won't be watching that jet AO
movie she did
now Michelle of course this is still
going we haven't finished the super yet
no we got to get to the end virro put
down your what did you what do we what
do we miss from nirro I don't I don't
know what we missed we're probably on a
tangent about Miss there we're probably
just got to get there soon but I
appreciate your first Super Chat being
that
yeah Olivia I love your thumbnail
John John sake John F M Gibson's
still working oh did you see the
Continental he's great I haven't seen
the when I went to see the Creator all
that I heard from the other critic
was them talking about how bad the
Continental was really the before and
after the Creator they just got back
together to keep talking about how bad
the Continental was so I yeah but you
know Mel Gibson
also not not good I mean people really
came out I mean Mel
Gibson I don't I don't Mel Gibson what
are his thoughts on the cont didn't have
um he wasn't
uh did he have like something in the
works and then it got C and
maybe he's been having the hardest time
getting leave the weapon five off the
ground I mean let's face I wonder why I
mean look we all know this career was
damaged and he had to have then he did
have a comeback directing wise with
hacksaw Ridge he was still able to work
because people still backed him as like
hey man you know he was just drunk said
some
a um oh galado do situation but there's
too many people here that come on the
channel don't let me watch M Gibson
movie now yeah ruining my fun I'll never
see the Lethal Weapon franchise now I
wanted to react to
Continental but there's people I'm
Jing actually anymore I want to
react heard all that I was like this
doesn't sound that interesting to me I
did hear Lethal Weapon five still in the
works I like the Lethal Weapon movies I
think they are really missing the point
of John Wick by trying these random
spin-offs I really don't think it's a
good idea was the it wasn't really the
world I don't think nobody cares that
much about the Continental without a
couple key actors Cory Handler hi guys
Green from New Orleans just want to
thank you for all the great content love
the channel say hi to Koy you can say hi
to Koy yourself Koy is uh always on
social media and he would love to reply
to you just say something really
offensive and he willou getou her scary
movie is actually the first screen movie
that's why this one really hits hard for
me oh PL it's PL
PL
big help we know plld big help plld is
it the same plld yeah I think so unless
you know I mean good to see boys it's
not that's not what your face looks like
in your avatar but you know pkes for
Doctor Who rank the new Doctor Who
doctors my favorite is Capal all right
easily Matt Smith
tenant
um I gotta say eckel's like at the
bottom for me I'd actually put what it
or above eckleson this is so hard I
don't want to R them really oh my God
for me it's Matt Smith tenant um Capaldi
Whitaker and then um
Tennant ten tenant at the bottom for me
yeah
really he might be in the middle for me
I know he's the quintessential for so
many people part of me feels I thought
he was creepy
unintentionally okay I mean sure I did
not I mean I I like I got invested in
Doctor Who because of him I I grew to
really like him but there was something
that felt off-putting about him at first
that I did not find particularly
Charming yeah it was I can I can I can
see why I thought it was creepy sure I
don't necessarily share that but I
understand where you would yeah I I get
it yeah I I I had such a hard time
moving past Eon because I really like
eckl uh I I it's hard I think for me
Capaldi and Matt Smith would grapple at
the top because I really like those two
portrayals um yeah
tenant I guess I would put in the
middle and then Whitaker and ccel thing
can kind of battle at the bottom I I
don't know I mean I like them all so
much for different reasons and it's hard
to rank them because they all are their
own take but they're all also you know
kind of familial to each other so that's
my tenative vague half ranking I guess
like I there's it's been hard to be like
oh this one's night and day like my
favorite you're like uh but yeah I mean
Matt Smith just had such a gripping he
he felt the most sort of like a man out
of time and had this sort of bubbly like
youthful but also old soul energy and
then Capaldi I just thought complimented
that so well in tandem um as the sort of
yeah like older more uh you know Haggard
version but who's trying to stay
connected to that you know Humanity I
don't know yeah real hard you
see okay you know what it was about
eckelson when he was being like fun and
harming he just creeped me out when he
was being like dramatic and serious
I wait wait wait are you talking about
ech you mean
echon what do you mean not tenant we're
not talking about tenant oh God no yeah
I okay so yeah I thought eklon I really
like ten Ten's usually my second
favorite wait a minute you said he was
creepy and you put him
Eon okay I think I got confused I
thought you you meant tenant as your
favorite no it goes Smith tenant okay
kaliy Whitaker eckelson that's a pretty
solid ranking yeah I know 10 is my
second favorite okay I'm G to be
excited about this was my least
favorite bring favorite one of them you
think this guy's creepy I mean I guess I
could see I mean yeah like Christopher
eckl is the most I I don't know like
there's yeah he has he kind of falls
into a center point for me between like
a Capaldi and and a tenant or Smith in
the sense of I thought Christopher eon's
light side was a nice compliment to the
dark did I say tenant I must have
up the saying my bad yeah it's all right
uh I thought I really like the joyous
side of eklon um but I as much as I do
love his portrayal I guess I kind of
have to put it lower okay did my bad
yeah yeah I was like damn the I could
understand not putting him at number one
but like least ten no my bad to i b
that I really thought I said it right
whereas eckl lands in my memory I'm like
did I really say that it's like I think
we would rank him for different reasons
it's like I I think eklon will
ultimately as much as I do have an
attachment to that performance he he
would rank lower just because everything
else that comes after is uh uh uh very
much more fully formed I don't think
Olivia likes Matt Smith I know she
thinks he he looks like a big toe I
remember her repeating that he does he
kind of looks a little bit like those
Mario Blockheads
yes he's got a weird looking at but he's
I love him yeah tenant and eckl can
battle at the top or I
mean Smith and and and and Capaldi and
then tenant and kapal can grapple for
two or three Whitaker and and whoever
can grapple for they're all grappling
but
the H I forgot my I forgot my thing um
there's a there's a thing was it Dr
yeah something something Matt Smith we
were talking about his toe
face hey that kind of looks like a toe
right there thumb
thumb I okay yeah because I mean no one
said it
um like oh you think eon's creepy what
about Kali I'm like well Capaldi
supposed to be creepy yeah like Capaldi
is supposed to be like off-putting like
old
stressed out I just don't want to say
coners again but but he's supposed to be
like a little creepy like that's kind of
the intention he's supposed to be a
little intense and a little almost scary
yeah yeah that like that's the purpose
of him yeah um he's not my favorite but
I thought he was very
effective and uh really endeared to him
yeah yeah uh yeah echol just didn't and
I think Olivia's favorite is actually
Eon I like him a lot I do honest I'm
just oh I mean John Hurt I don't know
he's barely in it man I don't really
ever counter who the I asked to risk
that you know I I'm not like oh oh that
that special is I love him this this
will be the first time we're going to
talk about Doctor Who on YouTube on
actual YouTube I know it's kind of weird
to be like oh we're going to really
like actually talk about it yeah I'm
sorry I didn't mean it no one's
to I really thought I said Eckles I
would never put tened at the I just
wouldn't I was surprised yeah I was
surprised did you see my reaction when I
was talking about I was like what do you
mean like no why would I say in that
moment I was like okay so there must
have
been yeah I think I just said that yeah
but in my head I was for sure CU I can
very much see how eckleson would come
across a bit creepy yeah in in the way
that maybe is not onp is is onp putting
the opposite of offputting I mean ten
it's a little creepy well and in that
sense like I don't disagree that like if
you thought that I could kind of see it
but but it makes more sense and he's
more fully fleshed into the role of I
think I think I I saw killgrave before I
ever saw uh him as Doctor Who and and I
had a little bit of I have to get past
that a little bit yeah yeah that makes
sense you know so I sort of just
Associated him as a bad guy and then
Harry Potter yeah okay yeah yeah yeah
barely remember Harry Potter okay anyway
yeah he does the tongue thing a lot no
guys sorry I did not mean I could I
could go into more depth for you if you
want me to prove this but no I'm not a
eklon is not my I think I even said a
sentence of support I think I even said
like eckl was to introduce I think I
even said something like that that he
was the one to introduce me yeah Bor
over oh I I do not like like okay I
do not like I hope God I think the
Cybermen are the worst you love Cybermen
what are you
talking they're like it's the dolls you
hate show no the doll oh man I'm ready
to I I fly to the moon every time the
doll show up on scre I love the
dolls I even like the doll episodes that
people don't generally like about the
dolls you know like when they do like
going do the like on the on the freaking
Whitaker one when they had like that one
doll oh great I love I love the dolls
but the Cyberman more often than not are
super boring I'm just saying
they are super boring you kind of know
what to expect a lot of the time I like
I liked the hunt the the the one guy in
the jod Whitaker one ones I think they
could have done more with that but the
one who's like half his humanity is like
coming back and he's got the Warped
broken helmet that was pretty cool oh
the one that had like the uh the Riff on
Frankenstein the Mary shy Frankenstein
yeah yeah that one was pretty cool that
guy was pretty cool but yeah yeah like
Cyberman as cool as they look kind of
feel like you know uh like a discount
version of doll this so boring yeah
delete fight the Doctor Who I'll fight
the hoo and's tooth and nail on that I'm
like you tell me what why they're
interesting let's go I got your emails
baby they're not even like they're not
even like fun bad at least dollx are
like you can like kind of laugh at them
well their person now the the troubling
the difficulty with Cybermen is that the
whole point is that they don't have
emotions so like that's you have to rely
on numbers and conniving and blah blah
whereas like the dolls are just like fun
to to be around even though they're evil
so yeah oh weeping angels yes yeah they
they know how to keep them they they I
don't think they've ever botched the
Weeping Angels delete delete delete yeah
they haven't really I mean they've done
and they found some pretty interesting
ways of and those are I mean in the chat
confer those are like created for the
new series right like I feel like those
are a pretty iconic you know because
dolls and Cyberman they all come from
before and I think they really handled
nicely all their weeping
angel corporations uh I I would like to
buy the Loki on Blu Ray would sound fun
um I want to watch the whole thing back
to back um yeah
yeah uh you can like we just started
from eckleson they pretty much give you
a decent re because the whole point is
the whole point is to be like who are
you I'm the doctor yeah I think I think
common consensus is hey if you're first
timer jump in with the new series start
at eckl and then yeah progress because
too he's shortlived so that gives gives
you a good primer for what the show is
you need to know who Rose is and then it
gives you a pretty quick regeneration so
actually funny enough in the grand
scheme it's kind of fortunate that his
tenure was short because it gives people
an easy entry point I'm I don't think I
could ever go watch those I Mayan I've
seen like clips of the old ones and I'm
like maybe when I'm
retired and I just have so much time on
my real time for this yeah yeah damn
what is the Super Chat yeah the gender
MC no light let's do this yeah the
gender of Silver Surfer isn't important
as say Miles Morales being half black
and Latino I just think it's risky for
Marvel to go with a female version of
the Silver Surfer because we know how
sex I mean we cannot have nice things
and like a a female Silver Surfer will
surely melt the brains of many you said
one one out of two and two uh even if
the writing is good you have some that
will hate the silver Ser that silver
server is female for me personally it's
not a deal breaker but do you think it's
a good idea I mean I think you're
absolutely right here I mean I can't
disagree with you uh on that in terms of
is there going to be a side of the
audience that's going to act like
they've been the most knowledgeable
biggest Silver Surfer fans of all time
and that the MCU is roting everything of
course there's going to be that side or
half of them they won't even be able to
tell you one comic they're from you know
uh it's only going to embolden the
people who watch the the Pander verse
special and think that Cartman's point
of view is the point of view of the
episode yeah yeah yeah yeah the people
who are like oh no get a diverse female
in there quick like you know I'm sure
it's not going to help if they do it I
guess the question is is like what is
the purpose of the choice to do it CU
that is true I think there's there's
something to reconsider there there is
like what like if we watch it and and
then let's say they get like a great
actress in it will it feel like oh yeah
like like honestly when I think ancient
one I think Tilda Swinton you know
that's what I think of and I think she
did such a memorable job in that role
yeah that she makes an she makes an
impression and I'm like what changing it
to cuz Silver Surfers for the most part
like you know
it's I wouldn't say he's monotone but
he's a little bit uh stoic know so I
don't really feel like we
need it doesn't that's why I'm saying OD
Dawson to be the that's what I'm saying
doesn't really matter to me but at the
same time does making it a woman really
bring anything different to it or change
it or elevate it or will feel like
there's a purpose to making Silver
Surfer a woman and at the same time even
if there's not a purpose is it really
offending anyone does it matter it's
weird it's like does there need to be a
purpose but I guess for the people who
get up in arms that reads as disregard
if they want to just avoid that then
yeah that's the safe thing but is there
a reason to do it not really my true
question is there a reason not to do it
yeah to avoid getting people upset but
that's the only thing I can think of I
mean and gender swapping has become this
this weird thing now too where I think
it's a fun and interesting thing to do
but it does feel like like the broader
application of that choice by Hollywood
has been to you know just kind of I
don't know the the rhyme and reason to
doing it where and when hasn't been as
solid as one would hope and I do wonder
if ragged wreck is correct if Galactus
does have a female Herald anyway I think
that's kind of the key to this because
then you I think then the argument goes
just do that character but obviously
Silver Surfer is the
icon my my feel feeling Remains the Same
like I don't really care but also I
don't think it's a strong enough
argument that like if it doesn't really
matter then who cares because that's not
going to help you fight the people who
are going to be the most annoying about
this what was the second topic you think
we talked about
most definitely wasn't super Surfer I
need to change the thumbnail all Sil
Surfers in there I need I need to update
it yeah um Omar elcott I think the
director of God of thank you for the
Super Chat should form r r direct th
five what do you guys
think oh the game the director got got
of war that would bring a very different
flavor um one that could bring it back
to yeah you know we haven't quite had an
epic Thor movie that really does feel
like the Fantastical epic mythology
weirdly feels like the thing that's
missing from the Thor franchise is is
that epic Thor movie because it they
don't do that in the first Thor movie
they were aiming more for that in in a
dark world but they definitely didn't
succeed and then instead of trying to
nail it down they just went the opposite
direction yeah you know which I think is
I that would be a cool thing if Thor
five could nail The Shakespearean and
obviously Norse uh we need the story and
Stakes to provide to Warrant it though
yeah exactly like it has to be a bit of
a Lord of the Rings or or a bit of a
Northman or something like that
something like really steeped in this
yeah
um and that would be really cool but it
would also need to be very much
dedicated to being that and probably not
too interconnected with other stuff a
th% no that that's what it's really all
about yeah for sure man for sure I agree
I agree John let's get some nasty Viking
Thor movies out here go all right guys
we're gonna end soon I gotta work on
some other videos we've each aged so
much since the I've had great time man I
haven't honestly I haven't wanted this
then I've had a great time yes even when
it got like serious and stuff I had a
great time Gerardo tutoro go back to the
beginning of the chat of the stream and
you'll find the answer gang is con con
con is saying my dear we gotta we got to
do something soon all of us I know I
need to put together a hangout yeah you
me I I barely ask anyone in my life if
they see me it's on a random night at
like 1100 p.m where I'm like hey I got
some time yeah you want to go down the
street hey are you free cuz I just got
free yeah that is my life you got 10
minutes yeah let's cram it in because
there's other things I've been working
on too outside of uh outside of here um
you know how do you present a nude women
on a serle not sexualizer I think you go
you double
down I think honestly I don't know big
ass big po I got BR brings back over you
guys I mean I I I am certainly here for
a voluptuous silver server but I think
all they do is they just go with a
Barbie physique apologize chest don't
you apologize and doesn't have too curvy
of a hip I don't know like they it'll I
think it'll ride on androgyny really
like the Silver Surfer has a very
masculine physique but like what does
Kevin sorbo's Sci-Fi show have anything
to do with yes of course my bad I didn't
mean it Gabby P that's Olivia saying you
got to end this that's yeah that's a
th%
hello
what what' she say
should I should we react to it or should
we prepare ourselves
mentally go Melissa Barrera apparently
posted something on her
Instagram this is why we this is why we
stayed live uh oh uh oh what do we got
what do we got what do we got let's go
we can view it here hold on a second we
have to log in log in Jes just go to
mine all right John you went to the
wrong one I went to the GRE
ala just go see if that works all right
this work this will be fine all right
perfect no now we go now we go back
we're we're like
Paparazzi hey John you don't how
how to do anything around here I do
you're already posted something this
better this is going to be the most
exciting thing all right we got it here
we go here we go here we go all right
got oh my God Instagram you are so
aggravating
sometimes not now we're good I'm going
to look at it right now okay view is
real yes all right John's got it babe
all right pause this first and foremost
I who put it up here yes my B my B my B
all right first and foremost I condemn
anti-Semitism and islamophobia I condemn
hate and Prejudice of any kind against
any group of people as a Latina proud
Mex let's just pause I think that is
exceptionally obvious yes I think that's
exceptionally You' bent over backwards
communicate don't need to have it's sad
that she has to have that be her
first and foremost I think it's very
very very obvious yeah
yeah well the OD is happen we're still
alive my God and it's very obvious
anyway please continue I haven't read
the rest of this let's see what she says
as a Latina and a proud Mexicana I feel
the responsibility of having a platform
that allows me the privilege of being
heard and therefore I have tried to use
it to raise awareness about issues I
care about and lend my voice to the in
need okay see this is where some people
get um this is where some people get uh
she thought she was paltin no no she's
uh she said that before she's mexan she
talked about um her people are also
colonized she was referring to
that okay let's read this again as
Latina as a proud mexicon I feel the
responsibility of having a platform and
allows me the privilege of being hurt
you see some people get upset that
celebrities or certain actors will take
this opportunity to have a voice to say
something but a lot of times what a lot
of times when people become actors is
because they're incredibly it's not all
of them but some of them become very
empathetic human beings you know they're
people who love to feel so if they feel
something for this feels strongly and
they have a platform they're going to
want to use it and it's within their
right to use it yeah well there's a huge
push pull from society about platforms
and the use there therein so you know
yeah all right every person on this
Earth regardless of religion race
ethnicity gender sexual orientation or
socio economic status deserves equal
human rights dignity and of course
Freedom safe place to live yes that is
pretty much what have what we have been
saying I believe a group of people are
not their leadership and that no
governing body should be above criticism
it's true that we've been saying the
whole stream true that whole stream is
that is that we've been saying that's
what she's been saying except for the
American government which is beyond all
reproach but anyway but no it's entire
time like it's pretty obvious everything
she's been saying people are not their
government like I like this it's it's
crazy to me that she's making this
statement when it's like guys it's crazy
she has to make this statement because
of the that spy glass said about
her when that's not when when it was so
obvious like she did not even to say
this you know it was like no it's pretty
obvious that yeah that that's this is
what she's been saying and now she's
just making it exceptionally clear
anyway Misha Collins was getting death
threats for speaking up um Jes I pray
day and night for no more deaths for no
more violence for uh peaceful
coexistence I will continue to speak out
for those that need it most and continue
to advocate for peace and safety for
Human Rights and Freedom SS an option
for me yeah stay by what you
believe in absolutely and I think she's
got way more people in her support more
now than ever because lot of people
probably just knew her as like who's
that girl from Scream you proba know now
people really know her name and I I
think she can know use this and uh the
part of me that feels concern for her is
will she will she be able to properly
work again will who who will be the
studio that is willing to uh take her
back on and if spy glass does want her
back for
scream will she be willing to do it you
know um I don't think the spy glass CEO
made her say any of this snap I don't
think at all no and I think the fact
that some people associate like I know
it's easy to if you're not in that
country a lot of people will often hear
about what the government is doing and
assume that is what all people are like
but that's never that's where we that's
never the case that's what social media
has truly given us that's what some
people say about
Americans we are the poster child for
that totally um so no I think this is I
think this was a a good a smart just
just a super clear statement for her to
have
made
um this is like it's weird because this
started off this stream was us saying
spy glass said some it didn't line
up and we were asking people what did
they like where exactly is the
anti-Semitism you you see people trying
to hunt down the anti-Semitism they
can't find it and then you conclude
everything that she just said here and
now she just puts it here to be like I'm
just going to make it really clear I'm
like yeah this is exactly what it was
you know so yeah good statement yeah now
she's gonna become super famous even
more famous than before they for all the
reasons she was hoping I mean hey I mean
if she can use it to do something she's
even more passionate about than acting
then go for
it anyway
uh so Lex Luther Lex luor the white the
white guy playing Lex Luther thank you
Gabby P for being our last Super Chat
but we should go back to the streamlabs
and thank you to Olivia for calling me
with breaking news yes from the news
desk we stayed live we were like we were
gonna stay live until
Marissa yes this was this was the stream
of the century for us that's right man
we do what we can we said we'd go till 2
I was it only like 4:30 yeah yeah we've
been in worse we've been in waste we'll
see your family tomorrow at some point
oh no where the streamlabs go here they
are hey we're there all right we got a
couple here a couple the last of our
questions okay so we did this one last
so we're moving on to question 29 let's
do this let's do this Who Would You cast
for the rest of the Justice League and
what do you think of mine Martian
Manhunter Mersa Ali originally had Lance
reic rest in peace absolutely deep
fake yep get it going uh let's see
Wonder Woman not sure for this one flash
Dylan O'Brien Hal Jordan Glenn Powell
and then we move on to the second half
of this scream
Labs that's clever oh Judah Miller
sending a weightlifting one we're
acknowledging right now thank you thank
you Judah Miller we'll get you on the
screen there there you go uh John
Stewart would be travante rhods I know
that name Batman Jensen akles bit of a
weird one Baron Taylor Johnson as well
uh so we'll have two Batman why not
Aquaman Alexander Ludwig don't know that
guy Constantine Matt Ryan not in Justice
League but Ryan Gosling in question as
well okay by the way big fan of both you
guys so we should be Cas in the
movie uh my let's see there's some good
pretty good picks here some pretty good
picks um so she doesn't have Superman in
here nope well there you go I want I
want Superman and Martian Manhunter I
want to make it impossible to
defeat yes maybe this what enemy
you throw at them it is
impossible oh my I the I mean if you
just make Martian Manhunter a Superman
then you can put all those uh gripes to
rest about them being all almost the
same character um hey I like let's see
let's just do a quick recast for funsies
Martian Manhunter I'm thinking that's
all state stand uh Dennis Hayes I'm
gonna go uh I'm gonna go uh oh what's
his name uh kefir Southerland kefir sure
uh Wonder Woman actually somebody in the
chat said Melissa berrera I could see it
but U my my pick has been adrea Arona
for a minute now I'm going ay Plaza sure
I would I would be there I would love to
see that uh
flash uh yeah Glenn Powell oh nice good
call on that yeah a thous % going with a
K I'm actually going DJ quals for cl
flash uh Hal Jordan um oh nice good one
just just just keep throwing Nathan
fillian in there Harrison for I want one
uninspired choice th% Harris sure John
Stewart I'll cast Trevor Noah oh very
good call there we go sure um Batman oh
I didn't get a chance to go who do you
want Oh for uh John Stewart John Stewart
who you want Oh easily uh Dave Chappelle
Dave Chappelle yeah this a good choice
Jensen Ackles who you cast as Jensen
Ackles uh Jerry P Jerry piki he's gonna
be Batman uh Aquaman Aquaman uh what are
we thinking what are we thinking who who
uh oh who be a good Aquaman yeah oh
that's
easy Bri Larson Bri larsson's Aquaman
why not uh Constantine I'm gonna cast
that comedian from Tik Tok who just got
cancelled because of his uh insensitive
standup routine that guy doing chapters
on this video is going Matt R there you
go Matt re instead of Matt Ryan will be
constant yeah yeah and uh that's a good
question thank you Ma thank question 29
yeah Au Plaza would be the whatever
woman I like it I like it I like all
these the gamer MJ we still have inside
out to for movies next year inside out
to Ghostbusters bad boys for if and
quiet place day one to name a few uh
yeah I'm like reasonably excited for all
them um quiet place day one I'm excited
for because uh John krinski is not
making it and I'm trying to see what
direction he'll take it in love that
you're covering Doctor Who specials I
love that show what's your favorite
who's your favorite doctor oh I've said
it it's eckl and reaction to the crisis
animated trailer i
n wa for John and Koy to cover mie I
would love the new crisis give the good
work on infinite Earth thank you gamer
MJ and then here it is my God Chris Wham
off much love and no need to shout to
showing solidarity for those right Chris
Wham off Chris Chris swam off um I do
want to shout something out we were
talking my friend and Mr Chris swoff who
just gave us some M like three
times in a row 500 bucks because
we've been U making sure to a whole
history there with the people who have
been part of the strike who have been
part of the channel um so thank you very
much the the he just he's got engaged
not long ago he's got a beautiful fiance
Chris W is a lucky lucky woman yeah and
I hope that you run out of money for
your wedding by just giving it all to
our live streams have your have your
honeymoon on the live stream so dude
Chris thank you so much for being like
the amazing gentleman that you are for
uh helping out the channel the Way You
Are doing and for just being an overall
gentleman congratulations on being
engaged for always helping people out uh
you're the man and thank you so
much for being you dude thank you so so
much and Happy Thanksgiving to you and
your family and your your fiance your
your beautiful human being thank you
Chris that's appreciate you very much
very very generous my man my man
my man dude your biceps are getting
called out in the chat right now good
today look at that look that's for clemp
right there the stream is what we do all
right John what do you think about Dave
filon I mean this is probably what so
many people have been waiting for I dude
yeah I mean it's the it's the move of
the century right here it seems like a
foregone conclusion ready for everyone
to get lost on Star Wars being like I
haven't seen all these animated
things he's putting in my liveaction
movies I'm excited for this not to fix
everything and I'm I'm excited to get
like I don't know what's going on maybe
slightly more unified material but that
doesn't fix everything everything
basically I'm excited for what seems
like a solid choice that will not make
everyone happy I don't know I I feel
like Dave filon out of anyone who's been
involved in Star Wars lately easily the
best easily the best chance easily the
greatest fit for it and uh he seems to
be the one who's right now it's about
winning back here it's they're in a
weird spot right now because they need
to they need to gain new fans to heal
the brand but they also have to win back
their old fans and you they got to do
both got you can't just win back your
old fans you got to grow your fan base
like it's just part of the game and but
when you when you're' been losing your
old fans that's a real problem I get
that people outgrow people grow aart in
relationships it's part of what happens
in life but with your Star Wars no you
got to maintain that yo um and and
I think filon is the solution to
that your your arms are getting a lot a
lot of atten it's all that g- fuel and
also I'm going to tell you guys about
the craziest deal Greg just made
oh I'm getting less money for G
fuel again dude it's the third time this
is the third time they're doing this I'm
getting less money for G Fuel and
because they already don't they they
barely pay anything yes you know yes and
and I'm always and I'm fine with that
I'm fine with that because I'm always
like I don't I'm always telling them
this I don't really care about the money
I just want the gfuel I'm always tell
save enough just with the complimentary
everyone who comes here would know knows
this behind the scenes Greg loves I
people ask me for gfuel a lot of times
before they film I'm always going I I
I'm I love gfuel and they they
offered less money and I was like okay
can you send me more cans though I it
wasn't I'll take no money it wasn't for
unlimited that's why they don't realize
like you guys have realize that's the
path we're headed down is you will not
compensate it's anything Financial you
will just be sending me like I just want
to get to a year supply of cans yeah
yeah lifetime supply yeah like all
that's all I'm trying to get to right
now it's like we're getting to a point
where you're so close there's going to
be no compensation just give me all the
cans my my exact
message hold a sec let me see if I could
just have John read this for the first
time I I am I I love that I am I am
gonna start lifting
uh in 2024 and gigachad John is coming
don't worry I'm the last guy now who has
to catch up to you guys gigachad John
don't read the out of respect just
because of contract don't read that
number
here okay but read read the chat that I
said re read read what I said this the
first time John's reading this this is
how much I love G so I'm just reading
you or am I reading the the above as
well no just me yeah man let's chat
about it what are the requirements and
as long as I can get a ton of g-
fuel cans hell you know what can I can I
drop the rate and get double the amount
of
cans on that guy and get me a couple G
fuel
shirts but hey I mean that's got to be
the kind of person you want on your
influencer roster like somebody who just
cares about the product don't get R all
the money I just want the G fuel yeah
hey and it benefits me and Co at the
very least and anybody who gets a
straight can on the way they were kind
enough to send me some G fuel send KO
some I'm still working through the
supply of gel they sent me the first
time so that's what I mean man like it
helps it really does and it does and I
and I be coming in with this Shaker you
know it keeps me spr a lot of work goes
on around here you know like we like
doing five hour long live streams this
is you know as you guys see we always do
five hours this is the same energy
expenditure as spending all day at a
theme park um so my my point is is that
um uh yeah you know and like I I I wrote
like a couple of screenplays this year
too on top of that and sometimes you
have writing at like 5: in the morning
because I get done editing at 1: in the
morning and uh GFI really helps out it's
not even sponsored just love
them anyway guys uh yeah we got to
bounce because there are still things to
wrap up we've been on for 4 hours and 20
and half hours 420 baby we it's the
perfect time to stop guys um I don't
know who's been here since the beginning
but thanks to you for if you you've been
here for any if you've been here for
longer than 20 minutes thank you so much
if you are just tuning in thank you so
much than you for being here um I I than
for making this a blast I feel like we I
we love blind wave too I feel like we
need really needed this stream today uh
it was a really like a cathartic stream
I would say Janine I'm pretty sure
you've been here since the
beginning thank you uh let's say some
bye to some people thank you to everyone
who contributed to our streamlabs thank
you Judah Miller for one last sticker
right there thank you sticky shouts out
to the people who gave like
massive massive like some a couple
people someone gave a 100 bucks someone
gave 50 Chris round for the 500
that's enormous thank you but if
you just contribute like a dollar I
appreciate it if you didn't contribute
just in the chat I appreciate you guys
being here really love today um great
way to lead into Thanksgiving and um
thank you to everyone uh for being here
so Matt Israel W dark car just saying
random names are popping up in our right
now
uh uh
uh uh uh Heather gear uh uh who we
got gamer
MJ Sentinel Tate
Prime Bonnie all righty everybody got to
head out thank you guys so much much
love sincerely uh I really love this one
and be well be well be thankful be I you
especially